Welcome to our second drink of heavy competition. This was our 100th episode of Office Ladies. We celebrated with champagne, gifts, a little bit of Dr. Peter Tibido stats. Yes, the Office Ladies' Facebook fan page sent us a song to celebrate our 100th episode. We listened to it together for the first time on the podcast. It's so fantastic. It warms my heart. I'll never forget that moment.
欢迎收听我们的第二杯“激烈竞争”。这是我们的第一百集《办公室女郎》。我们用香槟、礼物，还有一点皮彼多博士（Dr. Peter Tibido）的数据来庆祝。是的，《办公室女郎》的脸书粉丝页给我们发了一首歌来庆祝我们的第一百集。我们在播客中第一次一起听了这首歌。真是太棒了。它温暖了我的心。我永远不会忘记那一刻。
I know. It's so wonderful. And so many of our Office Ladies community wrote in to share about their joy of the office and of the podcast. I wanted to share this one. This came in from Mao T. They started listening to the podcast around 2022. They wrote to say, I was very late to the party when I got to the 100th episode. I also cried during the fan song. I freaking love your show and have been listening to the podcast as much as I can until I catch up with the corresponding episodes. Mao went on to thank us for the hard work we do and to congratulate us on the success
我知道。太棒了。我们《办公室女郎》社区的许多成员都写信分享他们对办公室和播客的喜爱。我想分享这封。这是毛（Mao T.）发来的。他们大约在2022年开始收听这个播客。他们写道：“当我看到第一百集时，我算是相当晚才加入的。在听粉丝之歌时我也哭了。我超级喜欢你们的节目，一直在尽可能多地收听播客，直到追上对应的集数。”毛接着感谢我们所做的辛勤工作，并祝贺我们节目取得成功。
of the show. And we just wanted to say, thank you, Mao. And we also wanted to share your letter because it really sat with me how timeless the office is and that our rewatch podcast will always be there for you. Whenever you find it in your office journey, you will never be late to the party. That's right. We're big believers and you're never too late to go to the party. Yes. Well, let's dig into some second drink tidbits. I have something fun to share about this episode. In early drafts, this episode was called Corporate Spy. Oh, so mysterious. Well, I'll kick off our mailbag with this from Maureen and Grand Rapids. Maureen said, hi, Angela and Jenna, I have listened to the podcast all the way through, and I've just started my second pass.
我们只想说，谢谢你，毛。我们还想分享你的信，因为《办公室》是如此经久不衰，而我们的重看播客会一直陪伴着你，这真的让我感触很深。无论你在办公室之旅的哪个阶段发现它，你都永远不会嫌晚。没错。我们坚信，加入永远不会太迟。好吧，让我们来了解一些“第二杯”的趣闻。关于这一集，我有一些有趣的事情要分享。在早期草稿中，这一集被称为《企业间谍》。哦，好神秘。好吧，我先用莫琳（Maureen）来自大急流城的来信开启我们的信箱。莫琳说：“嗨，安吉拉和珍娜，我已经把播客完整听了一遍，现在刚刚开始第二遍。”
I love the candy bag alts, and by the way, I love that I know the lingo of the show. But ladies, is there one from this episode that you liked? Okay, so Maureen, I love it when anyone asks us about the candy bag. You know, you've listened to our whole show. You're on your second pass. So you know I love a good candy bag. Can I tell you something quickly? What?
我喜欢糖果袋的备选片段，顺便说一句，我喜欢我懂这个节目的行话。但是女士们，这一集里有没有你们喜欢的备选片段？好吧，莫琳，当有人问起糖果袋时，我总是很高兴。你知道的，你听了我们的整个节目。你已经在听第二遍了。所以你知道我喜欢一个好的糖果袋。我能快点告诉你一件事吗？什么事？
Because it's funny to me that Maureen knows what a candy bag alt is, but I was in like a meeting with some folks at a network, and they were asking me about my time on the office and about the podcast. And I said, oh, we recorded this episode called Boom Roasted, and we dig into all the candy bag alts from Michael's Roast. And they're like, what are Candy Bag Alts? And I'm like, oh, my gosh, it's not like an industry term. It is an office-specific term.
因为我觉得很有趣，莫琳知道什么是糖果袋备选片段，但有一次我和某电视台的一些人在开会，他们问起我在《办公室》的时光和这个播客。我说，哦，我们录制了一集叫《痛快回击》（Boom Roasted），我们深入探讨了迈克尔回击中所有的糖果袋备选片段。他们问：“什么是糖果袋备选片段？”我说：“天哪，这不是行业术语。这是《办公室》专属的术语。”
And they don't listen to our podcast. Clearly not. But Maureen does. That's right. Well, Maureen, I actually found a section in the candy bag alts that I want to share with you. Are you ready for the title? It's titled, Other Seventh. Stuff cheese puff.
他们不听我们的播客。显然没有。但莫琳听。没错。好吧，莫琳，我其实在糖果袋备选片段中找到了一段想和你分享。你准备好听标题了吗？它的标题是：“其他第七个。塞进奶酪泡芙。”
Oh no. Is this cheese puff all that scene where we're throwing the cheese puffs in each other's mouth? Exactly. Oh my gosh. It's just a list. Are you ready? Yeah.
哦，不。这个奶酪泡芙是不是我们把奶酪泡芙扔进对方嘴里的那一幕？完全正确。哦，天哪。这只是一个列表。准备好了吗？准备好了。
Michael does a quote, no look toss into Pam's mouth. Michael throws it between his legs. Michael goes deep and catches one over his shoulder. Michael juggles three. All three cascade into his mouth. Michael blows one out of his mouth and catches it again. Pam simultaneously throws a puff into both Ryan and Michael's mouth. Michael walks in for the morning, taking off his coat, he catches a puff in his mouth.
迈克尔说了一句台词，不看目标扔进帕姆的嘴里。迈克尔把它从两腿之间扔过去。迈克尔来个远距离抛投，在肩膀上方接住一个。迈克尔同时抛接三个。三个都落入他的口中。迈克尔从嘴里吹出一个，然后又接住。帕姆同时把一个泡芙扔进莱恩和迈克尔的嘴里。迈克尔早上走进来，脱下外套，他用嘴接住一个泡芙。
Oh, my gosh. That is so funny. We shot so many options. But the one, and we talk about it in our breakdown, we talk all about this, is like how excited we were when the three-way toss actually worked. That was brilliant. That was like real joy. Yeah. That's like a sports moment.
哦，天哪。太搞笑了。我们拍了太多的选项。但是其中一个——我们在拆解环节中谈到了所有这些——就是当我们那个三人互投真正成功时，我们有多兴奋。那太精彩了。那就像是真正的快乐。是的。那就像是一个体育时刻。
It kind of is. Yeah. Okay. So there were also some alt endings, and I wanted to read one for you guys, but I'm going to need some help. Okay, so I'm going to read Michael and Ryan. Jenna, you read Pam, and Sam, can you read the stage directions? Sounds good. Okay.
确实有点像。是的。好吧，还有一些备选结局，我想为你们读一个，但我需要一些帮助。好吧，我来读迈克尔和莱恩。珍娜，你读帕姆，山姆，你能读一下舞台指示吗？听起来不错。好的。
Michael starts. All right, let's do it. No look this time. Michael reaches into the puff jar. There's not a lot left. We're getting low. He holds it for everyone to take another puff. Pam pulls something weird and furry and round
迈克尔开始。好吧，我们来吧。这次不看目标。迈克尔伸手去抓泡芙罐。剩下的不多了。我们快见底了。他拿着它让每个人再拿一个泡芙。帕姆从罐子里拉出一个奇怪、毛茸茸、圆圆的东西，大小跟泡芙差不多。
about the size of a puff out of the jar. Oh, my God, what is this? Oh, God. Oh, God. Oh, God. Is that a mouse? All three of them have very strong grossed out reactions. Antene. Oh, my gosh. So this would have ended with us realizing we'd been eating cheese puffs
哦，天哪，这是什么？哦，天哪。哦，天哪。哦，天哪。这是一只老鼠吗？他们三个都有非常强烈的恶心反应。安妮（Antene）。哦，天哪。所以这个结局本该是我们发现自己一直在吃一个底部有一只死老鼠的桶里的奶酪泡芙？是的。好吧，我们从来没拍过那个。那个没有。我们从没拍过那个。好吧，这一集的糖果袋备选片段里有很多我甚至还没来得及深入探讨的内容。有满满好几页的迈克尔访谈（Talking Heads）。它们太搞笑了。
out of a bucket with a dead mouse in the bottom? Yes. Okay, we never shot that. That did not. We never did that one. Well, there is so much in the candy bag alts for this episode that I didn't even dig into. There are pages and pages of Michael Talking Heads. They are so funny.
我们可能得进一步研究这个糖果袋，女士。好吧，你知道我喜欢一个有彩蛋的糖果袋特辑。我知道。所以把这个加入我们的清单。好吧，各位，请享用你们的第二杯“激烈竞争”。我是珍娜·菲舍尔。
We might have to investigate this candy bag further, lady. Well, you know I love a bonus candy bag episode. I know. So put this one on our list. All right. Well, everyone, please enjoy your second drink of heavy competition. I'm Jenna Fisher. And I'm Angela Kinsey.
我是安吉拉·金西。我们曾一起出演《办公室》。我们是最好的朋友。现在我们正为您带来终极的《办公室》重看播客。每周，我们会剖析一集《办公室》，并提供只有身临其境的两个人才能告诉您的独家幕后故事。我们是《办公室女郎》。嘿，孩子们！我是克里德大叔。系好安全带，因为《办公室女郎》刚刚突破了100集。太棒了。我们带来了香槟。我们要打开它。我们在上午10点之前又开始喝酒了。是的，因为这是第100集，如果没有你们，我们是不可能做到这一点的。
We were on the office together. And we're best friends. And now we're doing the ultimate ultimate. Office rewatch podcast just for you. Each week, we will break down an episode of the office and give exclusive behind-the-scenes stories that only two people who were there can tell you. We're the office ladies. Hey kiddos. It's Uncle Creed here. Buckle up because the office ladies just hit 100 episodes. Amazing. We brought champagne. We're going to open us. We're drinking again before 10 a.m. We are because it's 100 episodes and we could not have done this without you guys.
我们希望你们大家都能和我们在一起。哦，天哪。好吧，珍娜，别害怕。我以前开过香槟。我有点害怕。哦，你知道吗？我不应该把它对准杯子。山姆，我不会把它对准杯子的。
We wish you were all here with us. Oh my gosh. Okay, Jenna, don't be afraid. I've opened champagne before. I'm slightly scared. Oh, you know what? I shouldn't point it towards the glass. Sam, I won't point it towards the glass.
我很感激。好吧，我们开始吧。恭喜，山姆、卡西、科迪、科林、科林、玛丽莎、伊利亚、伊利亚、英斯莉。所有帮助我们制作这个节目的人。哦，天哪，录制结束后，我们一会儿要和团队一起庆祝。是的，我们收到了一些有趣的礼物。哦，我们确实有。
I appreciate that. Okay, here we go. Congratulations, Sam, Cassie, Cody, Colin, Colin, Marissa, Ilya, Ilya, I'm Slee. Everybody that helps us make this show. Oh, my. my gosh, we're going to be celebrating with our team later after we record. Yes, and we got some fun gifts. Oh, we do.
说到有趣的礼物，我向你们保证，这些袋子和礼物无关，但在那张桌子底下，那些是给你们的。庆祝100集快乐。山姆，披萨？我向你保证那个袋子……这是唯一的袋子。你给我们买披萨了吗？袋子和这无关。你怎么会有达美乐披萨？
Speaking of fun gifts, I promise you the bags are unrelated to the gifts, but under the table there, those are for you. Happy 100. Sam, pizza. I promise you the bag, it's the only bags. Did you get us pizza? The bags are unrelated. How do you have Domino's pizza?
山姆，你这个星球上的人才。你们。这就像其中一个龙卷风。不，这就像其中一个火山碗。哦，天哪。这就像帕姆的艺术学校。这是帕姆的艺术学校的碗。恭喜大家，伙们。哦，一小瓶酒精和吸管。山姆，这是最可爱、最贴心的东西。你太甜了。
Sam, get a person on the planet. You guys. It's one of those tornadoes. No, it's one of those volcano bowls. Oh my gosh. It's like Pam's art school. It's Pam's art school bowl. Congratulations, guys. Oh, little bottles of alcohol and straws. Sam, this is the cutest, most thoughtful thing. You are so sweet.
现在，记住，这道潘趣酒的关键在于它字面意思上就是你想要的任何东西。哦。哦，天哪。我们不能既有一个火山碗，又……好吧，我们今天要喝香槟。我们把火山碗留到我们公司的聚会再用。山姆，我太喜欢了。这太贴心了。贴心的惊喜礼物。桌子底下。桌子底下。这就像奥普拉说“看你们的椅子底下”一样。你得到一辆车。你得到一个火山碗。山姆，谢谢你。我们也有东西送给你们。我等不及要让你们看到了。但我们要同时把它送给你们。没错。因为卡西今天在Zoom上。嗨，Zoom上的卡西。嗨，伙们。卡西，你错过香槟了。我知道。干杯，珍娜。干杯，女士。我有一杯香槟和一个杯子。开启美好一天的好方式。听着，今天我们最终会讨论《激烈竞争》，但我们想把今天《办公室女郎》的快速事实献给我们第一百集。
Now, remember, the key to a punch is it's literally whatever you want. Oh. Oh, my gosh. We can't have a volcano bowl and... Okay, we're going to have champagne today. We'll save the volcano bowl for our company get together. Sam, I love it. That is so sweet. Sweet, surprise gift. Under the table. Under the table. This is like Oprah when she's like, look under your chair. You get a car. You get a volcano bowl. Sam, thank you. And we have something for you guys. I can't wait for you to see. But we're going to give it to you all at the same time. That's right. Because Cassie's on Zoom today. Hi, Cassie on Zoom. Hi, guys. You're missing champagne, Cassie. I know. Cheers, Jenna. Cheers, lady. I've got a glass of champagne and a cup of A nice way to start the day. Listen, today we will eventually be discussing heavy competition, but we would like to dedicate our fast facts to Office Ladies today to our 100th episode.
没错。那我们要开始吗？我等不及了。快速事实一，《办公室女郎》播客于2019年10月16日首播。所以现在我们刚刚过去两年多一点，已经发布了100集。100集。并且在今年12月，我们将迎来2亿次下载。
That's right. So should we get into it? I can't wait. Fast fact number one, Office Ladies podcast debuted on October 16th, 2019. So here we are just a little over two years later, having released 100 episodes. 100. And in December of this year, we will hit 200 million downloads.
什么？我要上桌子了。哦，不。2亿次下载。我在桌子上。这不是因为香槟。这是因为兴奋。这是一个音频节目。
What? I'm getting on the table. Oh, no. 200 million downloads. I'm on the table. This isn't from Champaign. This is excitement. It's an audio program.
他们看不到你。我在桌子上。不，我不知道怎么下来。她被缠住了。哦，天哪。哦，天哪。你……我的妈妈是露西。我是戴着眼镜的你妈妈。
They cannot see you. I'm on the table. No, I don't know how to get down. She's tangled. Oh, Jesus. Oh, my gosh. You're my mom is Lucy. I'm your mom with your glasses.
你是露西。我们的工作室。你简直把那位女士当成汤姆·克鲁斯对待了。哦，我真像汤姆·克鲁斯。哦，不。沙发。奥普拉的沙发。我知道。你做到了。听着，当我们开始这个播客时，我们做梦也没想到它会变得这么大。我没有想到。没有。也没想到它会这么受欢迎，或者它能引起人们的共鸣，或者我们会拥有这样一个社区。这对我的生活意义重大，对我意义重大。它改变了我的生活。就像《办公室》改变了我的生活一样，这也改变了我的生活，因为它给我带来了一份工作，让我离家人更近，离我最好的朋友更近。哦，女士，别让我哭。好吧，这是真的。我也有同感。我只是深表感激。我也是。真的非常感激。伙们，我们太
You're Lucy. our studio. You just full on Tom Cruise that lady. Oh, I Tom Cruise did. Oh, no. The couch. Oprah's couch. I know. You did it. Listen, when we started this podcast, we never could have imagined that it would grow this big. I did not imagine it. No. Or that it would be as popular or that it would resonate with people or that we would have this community that we have. And it means, so much to my life, it means so much to me. It has changed my life. In all the ways that the office changed my life, this has changed my life as well, because it has brought me a job that brings me closer to my family and closer to my best friend. Oh, lady, don't make me cry. Well, it's true. I feel the same way. I am just deeply grateful. Me too. Truly grateful. You guys, we're so
感谢你们了。感谢你们每周给我们留下的所有评论和消息，感谢你们与我们分享的点滴，这对我们意义重大。我们喜欢做这件事。我们喜欢。我喜欢。我有一个非常有趣的快速事实二。一个有趣的快速事实。当你说这个的时候，我要喝一口香槟。我喜欢我们的信件。我和英斯莉一起浏览了我们的大量信件。安吉拉，你浏览了我们的大量实体信件。如果你写信给厄尔沃夫（Earwolf）办公室并寄东西，我会去处理。珍娜和英斯莉负责处理我们的数字信件。是的。
thankful for you. For all of the comments and messages you leave us every week, the things that you share with us, it just means so much to us. And we love doing this. We love it. I love it. I have a really fun fast fact number two. A fun fast fact. I'm going to take a sip of champagne while you say that. I love our mail. I go through a lot of our mail with Ainslie. You go through a lot of our physical mail, Angela. If you write a letter to the Earwolf offices and send things I go through that. Jenna and Ainsley go through our digital mail. Yes.
这就是我们的分工方式。在我们的数字信件中，我们收到了一封来自彼得·蒂比多（Dr. Peter Tibido）博士的信。蒂比多博士？我在路易斯安那州认识很多蒂比多。安吉拉，他是这么说的。好的。我和我的妻子、女儿们，注意到你们俩在播客中有多么喜欢说两句话。
That's how we divide it up. In our digital mail, we got a letter from Dr. Peter Tibido. Dr. Tibido? I know a lot of Tibadoes in Louisiana. Here's what he said, Angela. Okay. My wife, daughters, and I, notice how much you both love saying two things on your podcast.
哦，不。哦，不。什么？女士。还有“太棒了”（Amazing）。所以我追踪了这两个词在播客中出现的次数。哦，蒂比多博士。女士，他追踪了。
Oh, no. Oh, no. What? Lady. and amazing. So I tracked down just how many times that comes up in the podcast. Oh, Dr. Tippano. Lady, he tracked it.
这太棒了吗？这太棒了。他只能追踪到我们的第92集。好吧。但在过去的92期播客中，我们说了636次“女士”（Lady）。哦。我们说了786次“太棒了”（Amazing）。哇。但他用图表进行了细分。这些图表太不可思议了。平均每集我们说“太棒了”九次，每集说“女士”七次。他说，从第31集到第47集有一段时期，我们对这两个词的使用量真的增加了。我们在鸡尾酒那一集里一共说了34次“太棒了”和“女士”。那天我们怎么了？
Was it amazing? It was amazing. He was only able to track up to our 92nd episode. Okay. But over the last 92 podcasts, we have said, Lady, 636 times. Oh. And we have said Amazing 786 times. Wow. But he broke it down with charts. The charts are incredible. On average, we say the word amazing nine times per episode and we say Lady seven times per episode. He said there was a stretch from episodes 31 through 47 where our use of both words really went up. We said, amazing and lady, a total of 34 times in the cocktails episode. What was up with us that day?
好吧，我查了一下，第31集到第47集是从2020年6月到2020年9月。夏天就是夏天的氛围。这也是大流行病的核心时期。我们当时在衣橱里从家里进行录制。我想我们在应付。我想我们是在乱用“女士”这个词来应付。而且它们太棒了，因为我们待在衣橱里，然后我们就说，这太棒了。我也这么觉得。或者，你知道我觉得什么？什么？我觉得做我们的播客感觉太棒了。这让我们在大流行期间得到了极大的治愈。真的，千真万确。那是一个逃离。那就像是一个逃离。就像每次我走进那个衣橱，我就想，我今天又能和珍娜一起闲逛了。是的。而且我们可以谈论非常有趣的事情。这就是为什么科迪、卡西、山姆还有你，真的成为了我最好的朋友，因为你们是我在那个Zoom上唯一见过的人。百分之百。是的。我们开始播客时总是先分享一些。是的。
Well, I looked it up and episodes 31 through 47 ran from June of 2020 to September 2020. Summer is summer vibes. It was also right in the heart of the pandemic. We were recording from home in our closets. I think we were coping. I think we were thrown out the late. ladies to cope. And they're amazing, because we were in closets and we're like, this is amazing. I think so. Or, you know what I think? What? I think doing our podcast felt amazing. And it was such a
就像在学校里你有围坐圆圈时间然后进行分享一样。是的。那是每一个播客Zoom的第一部分。我想这就是为什么我们觉得它们太棒了。我同意。好吧，我们说“女士”最多的一集是《政变》（The Coup）。我们说了19次。这让我喷笑出来。
great healing thing for us through the pandemic. Really and truly. It was an escape. It was an escape. Like every time I walked into that closet, I was like, I get to hang out with Jenna today. Yeah. And we get to talk about really fun things. And that's really when like Cody and Cassie and Sam And you, like, became my best friends because you were the only people I ever saw on that Zoom. 100%. Yeah. We would start our podcast just sort of sharing. Yeah.
我们说“太棒了”最多的一集是《旅行推销员》（Traveling Salesmen），我们说了20次。但接下来这是我最喜欢蒂比多博士写的东西。蒂比多博士。他说，可悲的是，有几次《办公室女郎》感觉并不太棒。我们只用了一次。什么？哪一集？
Like in school where you have circle time and you share. Yeah. That was the first part of every podcast Zoom. I think that's why we thought they were so amazing. I agree. Well, our biggest lady episode was the coup. We said it 19 times. It made me snort laugh.
《多元化日》（Diversity Day）、《男孩与女孩》（Boys and Girls）和《带女儿上班日》（Take Your Daughter to Work Day）。哇。然后他说，还有“女士”。有四期播客完全没有使用“女士”这个词。它们是《性骚扰》（Sexual Harassment）、《酒会游轮》（Booze Cruise）、《德怀特的演讲》（Dwight's Speech）和《客户调查》（Customer Survey）。我觉得很难相信我们一次“女士”都没说。是的。但蒂比多博士有数据。
Our biggest amazing episode was Traveling Salesmen, We said it 20 times. But then this was my favorite thing that Dr. Tibido wrote. Dr. Tibido. He said, sadly, there were a few times when the office ladies weren't feeling amazing. And we only used it one time. What? Episode.
好吧，我们不得不问蒂比多博士为什么。为什么要追踪这个？我的意思是，我们喜欢追踪各种东西。但究竟是什么驱使他追踪所有这些？他说，我是一名哲学博士（PhD）科学家，我喜欢追踪任何类型的数据。珍娜，这就像你的灵魂伴侣。难道我内心深处是一个哲学博士科学家，而我自己却不知道？
Diversity Day, boys and girls, and take your daughter to work day. Wow. And then he says, and lady. There were four podcasts where there was no use of the word lady at all. And those were sexual harassment, booze crews, Dwight's speech, and customer survey. I find it hard to believe that we didn't say lady one time. Yeah. But Dr. Tibado has the stats.
女士，你喜欢追踪各种东西。也许我是一个哲学博士科学家。也许你是。他说，不管出于什么原因，这是我和我的家人很早就开始关注的事情，我承担这件事只是为了看看结果如何。我会一直坚持到最后，而且我绝不会错过任何一集。蒂比多博士，我们必须送你一件“女士”运动衫。
Well, we had to ask Dr. Tibido why. Why track it? I mean, we love to track stuff. But what compelled him to track all of this? And he said, I am a PhD scientist. and I love tracking data of any kind. Jenna, this is like your soulmate. Am I a PhD scientist on the inside and I don't know it?
我们要把你的整套东西都送过去。家庭“女士”运动衫。是的，每个人都有一件“女士”运动衫。谢谢。非常感谢你，蒂比多博士。那封信让我的一天都变得美好了。我想看那个条形图。我想看。我们会发布的。哦，我们会把它发到快拍里。我们会的。他的女儿制作了一些与这些事实相配套的图表，我们也可以把它们发出来。我太喜欢这一家人了。我也是。现在，安吉拉，你说过，给我留一个快速事实。所以你是快速事实三，我不知道它是什么。是的，珍娜。我是快速事实三。我要向我们在脸书上的《办公室女郎》播客粉丝页致以巨大的谢意，
You love to track things, lady. Maybe I'm a PhD scientist. Maybe you are. He said, for whatever reason, this is something that my family and I caught on about early, and I took this on just to see how it went. And I will do this all the way to the end, and I will never miss an episode. Dr. Tibado, we have got to send you a lady sweatshirt.
他们提交了一首歌来庆祝我们的第一百集。我们必须听听。好吧，现在，你听过这个了吗？因为我还没听过。我还没听过。我希望我们能实时一起第一次听到它。好的。那么我们开始吧。
We're going to send your whole whole thing. Family lady sweatshirt. Yeah, everybody gets a lady sweatshirt. Thank you. Thank you so much, Dr. Tibodeau. That piece of mail, it made my day. I want to see the bar graph chart. I want to see it. We'll post it. Oh, we'll put it in stories. Let's do it. And his daughter made some graphics to go along with the facts, and we can put those up as well. I love this family. Same. Now, Angela, you said, save me a fast fact. So you are fast fact number three, and I don't know what it is. Yes, Jenna. I am fast fact number three. and I want to give a huge shout out to our Office Ladies' podcast fan page over on Facebook,
播客里有100秒。我的一百八万四千八百秒。别让我哭。我们每周三都在收听。在快速事实。和深度挖掘。还有客串明星和“糖果百科”。新的计划和看法。
and they submitted a song to celebrate our 100th episode. We have to hear it. Okay, now, have you heard this yet? Because I have not heard this. I have not heard it. I wanted us to hear it together in real time for the first time. All right. So here we go.
还有休息室里的心碎。1800秒。那就像看了《办公室》。只有两次。你有一群猫。有一只吃了一只鸟。你帮我们背书包。并向我们展示了我们的价值。
100 seconds are in the podcast. My hundred eighty-four thousand eight hundred seconds Don't get me cry We've all been listening every Wednesday In fast facts And deep dives With guest stars and cantapedia New plans and perception
你激励了我们所有人。非常感谢你们。激励了我们所有人。从你的《办公室女郎》脸书粉丝页庆祝。你激励了我们所有人。太美了。
And heartbreak in the break room 1,800 seconds That's like watching the office Only two times You have a bunch of cats And one ate a bird You helped us with our backpacks And showed us just what we're worth
你激励了我们……我真的说不出话来。只是确认一下，我们都在哭，对吧？我们都在哭。这太、太贴心了。
You've inspired us All We thank you so much Inspired us All Celebrate from your office ladies' Facebook fan page You've inspired us all Beautiful
天哪，太棒了。非常感谢你们。我真的很想表示由衷的感谢，那是团队共同努力的结果，我要
You've inspired us on us I can't really talk just checking in we're all crying right we're all crying that was so so kind
宣读一下所有参与制作这首精彩歌曲的人。这是喜悦的眼泪，伙们，这是喜悦的眼泪。
my goodness that was so great thank you so much I really want to give a big thank you that was a group effort and I'm going to
汉娜·拜尔斯（Hannah Byers）想出了这个主意。米凯拉（Michaela）和扎克·道奇（Zach Dodge）这对夫妻档演唱了它。娜蒂斯·塞丰（Natisse Cephone）和米凯拉·道奇（Michaela Dodge）填了词。是不是很棒？我也知道你们当中脸书页面上的很多人都在发来消息。非常感谢你们。米歇尔（Michelle）、尼基（Nikki）和布拉德（Brad）在帮我，接下来的几天里，我们会把你们所有的消息都发到我们的Ins快拍里。非常感谢你们。《办公室女郎》脸书粉丝页。我还是有点说不出话来。我知道。我几乎从头哭到尾。猫吃鸟和背包那个梗真的戳中我了。那是对我们做的一个彩蛋特辑的致敬，我在那里分享了一些关于我的社交焦虑和应对机制的事情。当我分享那个时，那是一件非常脆弱的事情，我甚至质疑过这样做是否合适。不管怎样，那对我意义重大。我知道。我知道，女士。我知道。就在你让我们哭泣的时候，你告诉我们，基本上，如果你听过
read off who all was part of that amazing song these are happy tears guys these are happy tears
《办公室女郎》，你其实只看了两遍《办公室》。我喜欢这样。好吧，天哪，我想我们需要一分钟。我想我们需要一分钟。我们休息一下。当我们回来时，我们将把这一集的剩余时间用于剖析《激烈竞争》。好的，我们回来了。
so Hannah Byers had the idea for it Michaela and Zach Dodge, who are a husband and wife team, performed it. And Natisse Cephone and Michaela Dodge wrote the lyrics. Isn't that wonderful? And I also know a lot of you guys on the Facebook
我们笑过了。我们哭过了。我们喝了一点香槟。这真的很好。谢谢。香槟，这是干型经典起泡酒（Brut Classique）。好吧？弗朗索瓦（Francois）出品。
page are sending in messages. Thank you so much. Michelle, Nikki, and Brad are helping me, and we're going to put all of your messages over the next few days into our Insta stories. Thank you so much. Office Ladies, Facebook fan page. I'm still kind of speechless. I know. pretty much wept through that whole thing. You really got me with the cat eating the bird and the backpack. That's a reference to a bonus episode that we did where I shared a little about my social anxiety and my coping mechanisms. And that was a really vulnerable thing when I shared that and I questioned doing it. Anyway, that just meant a lot. I know. I know, lady. I know. And just when you had us crying, you told us that basically, if you've listened to
我永远是经典，宝贝。你知道吗？我视力太差了，我看不清。没关系。但它非常好。这是弗朗索瓦的。这就是我们需要知道的。顺便说一句，在休息期间，山姆和珍娜一直在取笑我爬上桌子的事。
Office ladies, you've only watched the office twice. I love that. Okay. Well, gosh, I think we need a minute. I think we need a minute. Let's take a break. And when we come back, we will dedicate the rest of this episode to breaking down heavy competition. All right, we are back.
好吧，因为这是一个播客。我知道这是一个播客。我们很感激。2亿次下载。这是一件大事。我知道我得做点什么。我当时想，我得做点什么。我该做什么？
We've had a laugh. We've had a cry. We've had a little champagne. It's really good. Thank you. Champagne, it is Brut Classique. Well? By Francois.
我很欣赏这种能量。我是。我很欣赏。你总是带着这种能量出现。谢谢。山姆录了像。卡西拍了照片。这会发到播客的快拍上。我们要剖析《激烈竞争》吗？我们开始吧。这是第五季第二十四集，由莱恩·科（Ryan Coe）编剧，肯·惠丁汉姆（Ken Whittingham）执导。我来给你做个总结。请吧。迈克尔强迫德怀特在效忠查尔斯·迈纳（Charles Miner）和邓德米夫林与效忠迈克尔之间做出选择。这导致他们俩大打出手。是的。迈克尔试图窃取德怀特的顶级客户。事情会变得很难看。这是一场激烈的竞争。是的。而安迪由于和安吉拉分手而依然心碎，他怀疑
I'm always classic, baby. You know what? My eyesight's so bad, I can't read it. It's all right. But it's very good. It's Francois. That's what we need to know. By the way, during break, both Sam and Jenna were just making fun of me getting on the table.
也许帕姆对吉姆有控制欲，也许虐待了他。于是他开始给吉姆提供一堆未经请求的建议，这反而适得其反，因为吉姆恶作剧地让他吐露了他和帕姆之间的关系非常糟糕。这就引发了整个支线剧情。是的。但这一集以一个非常著名的开场白开始。奶酪泡芙开场白。确实如此。我把它命名为“奶酪泡芙”。我很喜欢拍这个开场白。我有好多问题想问你。我有好多问题。我们要描述一下吗？描述一下。好的。是帕姆、迈克尔和莱恩以各种方式把奶酪泡芙扔进对方嘴里。没错。
Well, because it's a podcast. I know it's a podcast. We appreciated it. 200 million downloads. That's a big deal. I knew I had to do something. I was like, I got to do something. What do I do?
这就像你在油管（YouTube）上看到的那些视频，一个人把篮球砸向墙的背面，它撞到墙的另一边然后进了篮筐。这就是你们在做的，但你们是用奶酪泡芙做的。我喜欢这个呼应，因为，
I appreciated the energy. I did. appreciated it. You always show up with that. Thank you. Sam videoed it. Cassie took photos. It'll go on the pod stories. Should we break down heavy competition? Let's do it. This is season five, episode 24, written by Ryan Coe and directed by Ken Whittingham. I'm going to give you a summary. Do it. Michael forces Dwight to choose between either his loyalty to Charles Minor and Dunder Mifflin or Michael. And this results in the two of them going to war. Yeah. And Michael trying to steal Dwight's top clients. It's going to get ugly. It's a heavy competition. Yeah. And still hurting from his breakup with Angela, Andy suspects that
记住，这就是迈克尔在最后一天跑出邓德米夫林时带走的东西。你有问题。我们为此收到了海量的粉丝来信。所以首先我们联系了编剧莱恩·科，
maybe Pam is being controlling of Jim, maybe mistreating him. So he starts offering Jim a bunch of unsolicited advice, which backfires when Jim pranks him into confiding that things are terror. between him and Pam. It starts this whole runner. Yeah. But this episode begins with a very famous cold open. The cheese puff cold open. It is. I titled it the cheese puff. I loved doing this cold open. I have so many questions for you. I have so many questions. Should we describe it? Describe it. All right. It's Pam, Michael and Ryan tossing cheese puffs into one another's mouths. in various ways. Right.
想了解这个开场白的灵感是什么。
It's like the things you see on like YouTube of where the guy bounces the basketball off like the back of a wall and it hits the other side of the wall and it goes in the hoop. That's what you guys are doing, but you're doing it with cheese puffs. And I love the callback because,
他的回答太搞笑了。太棒了。我听的时候差 点把咖啡喷出来。是的，我们得放出来听听。嗨，珍娜。嗨，安吉拉。谢谢你们让我谈谈我的那一集。珍娜，你曾提到你很喜欢和奶酪球一起拍摄那个开场白，并且你想知道它的灵感从何而来。
remember, this is what Michael took when he ran out of Dunder Mifflin on that last day. You have questions. We got a fan mail flurry about this. So first we reached out to writer Ryan Coe. to find out like what was the inspiration for this cold open.
我的回答是，这主要产物是精疲力竭。我倒回一点说。是的，你知道的，对于我那一集的初稿，我写了一个开场白，关于莱恩认为帕姆对有好感，但没有人喜欢这个点子，所以它被扔掉了，我们需要一个新的开场白。而在这个时候的这一季，所有的编剧都真的筋疲力尽。正如你所记得的，在第五季中，我们制作了28集，它们是在连续10周的制作中拍摄的，然后休息以便史蒂夫去拍电影，然后又是连续18周的制作。我待过的其他节目，我告诉过他们有一段连续18周的制作期，
His response was so funny. It's so good. I actually spit out my coffee while listening to it. Yeah, we got to play it. Hi, Jenna. Hi, Angela. Thanks for letting me talk about my episode. Jenna, you had mentioned that you love shooting that cold open with the cheese
他们根本不相信我们做到了这一点。在情景喜剧中，通常的做法是制作两三周然后休息一周，以便演员们恢复体力，编剧们也能赶上进度，不至于彻底精疲力竭。所以连续18周简直就是一场死亡行军。我记得当时有个编剧要下去看看片场发生了什么。保罗或者某个人说：“千万别下去。演员们累了，正表现得像个大混蛋。”所以，是的，我记得那是一段艰难的时期。所以在第五季的后半段，我们总是落后进度，我觉得我们几乎每天都要工作11个小时甚至更久。
balls and you were wondering where it came from. I remember that it was most of all a product of exhaustion. I'll back up a bit. Yeah, you know, for the first draft of my episode, I had written a cold open about how Ryan thought Pam had a crush on him, and no one liked it, so it was tossed out, and we needed a new cold open. And at this point in the season, all the writers were really exhausted. In season five, as you recall, we did 28 episodes, and they were shot in a 10 consecutive weeks of production, then a break so Steve could do a movie, and then 18 straight weeks of production. Other shows I've been on, I've told them that there was a stretch of 18 straight weeks of production.
我记得敏迪（Mindy）真的很生气，这意味着她没有社交生活，并说类似“因为该死的节目我要孤独终老了”这样的话。总之，我们都精疲力竭，我们正试图想出一个新的开场白，要么是亚伦·舒尔（Aaron Shur）要么是保罗。他们两个都是那种非常擅长无中生有的人。其中一个人说：“我不知道，他们正把奶酪球扔向对方。”然后每个人都说：“太好了，我们什么都不用写了。那太棒了。”
production and they do not believe we did that. And sort of sitcoms, it's more common to do two or three weeks on of production and then one week off so that the actors can recover and so the writers can catch up and don't get totally burned out. And so 18 straight weeks is a total death march. And I remember at that time a writer was going to go down and check out what was going down on set. Paul or someone was like, do not go down there. The actors are tired and are acting like huge asses. So, yeah, I remember it was a sort of rough time. And so for the last half of season five, we were always behind, and I feel like we were working 11 or more hours pretty much every single day.
好吧，这就是开场白的奶酪球。好的，接下来。至于关于写这一集的其他任何事情，那是很久以前的事了。我真的记不清了，因为我太累了。莱恩，这让我们的一天都过得很开心。我的意思是，看看这段精彩的喜剧，它竟然来自每个人都精疲力竭的状态。疲惫。是的。
I remember Mindy was really mad that it meant she had no social life and said something like, I'm going to die alone because of this damn show. So anyway, we were all very spent, and we were trying to come up with a new cold open, and it was either Aaron Schur or Paul. They were both the guys that were really good at making something out of nothing. One of them said, I don't know, they're throwing cheeseballs at each other. And everyone's like, great, we don't have to write anything. That's awesome.
你们可能还记得，莱恩就是那个在跑过测速仪标志时摔倒的编剧。是的。所以，莱恩，非常感谢你与我们分享你对奶酪球开场白的记忆。如果那一周我们表现得像个混蛋，请原谅。我想我们当时都很累而且脾气暴躁。我想是的。女士，你刚才说你有几个问题。我有。
Okay, that's the cold open cheese balls. All right, next. As far as anything else about writing the episode, it was a long time ago. And I don't really remember because I was tired. Ryan, that made our day. I mean, look at this amazing piece of comedy that came out of just everyone being so tired. Fatigue. Yes.
我来回答问题。好的。我知道在其他任何一集中，只要我们必须扔什么东西，你绝不可能在第一次拍摄时就成功。但史蒂夫把奶酪球朝你扔过来的那个镜头，你接住了，你嚼了。你直接看着镜头。当时我想：“我的天哪，看看她。”我太骄傲了。我想：“好吧，像《双面女间谍》（Alias）里的悉尼·布里斯托（Sydney Bristow）一样，你能做到那个吗？”
You guys might remember Ryan is our writer who wiped out while running past the speed reader sign. Yes. So, Ryan, thank you so much for sharing your memory with us of the cheeseball cold open. And sorry if we were assholes that week. I guess we were all tired and grouchy. I guess so. Lady, you said you had some questions. I do.
珍娜，这就像是你的高光时刻。好吧。我要告诉你一件事。好的。当我上高中时，我没有丰富多彩的社交生活。所以你把奶酪球扔向自己的脸？没有。什么？我看了很多电影。
I'm here to answer questions. All right. So I know from other episodes where anytime we had to throw something, you don't get it on the first take. But that shot of Steve throwing the cheese puff ball at you, you caught it, you chomped it. You looked right to camera. And I was like, my girl, look at her. I was so proud. I was like, okay, Sidney Bristow on alias, can you do that?
好吧。当我看电影时，我会吃爆米花。我开始把爆米花往空中扔并接住它。你自己一个人。是的。好吧，这在我后来的生活中得到了回报。确实如此。
That. Jenna, this is like your moment. All right. I'm going to tell you something. Okay. When I was in high school, I did not have a vibrant social life. So you threw cheese balls at your face? No. What? I watched a lot of movies.
所以不要为我感到难过。我才没有为……我也看了无数好电影，我对电影有着极好的审美。是的。所以我非常擅长用嘴接食物。我知道。还有，我和我姐姐会互相扔爆米花。当然，当然。
Okay. And when I watched the movies, I would eat popcorn. And I started throwing the popcorn up in the air and catching it. By yourself. Yeah. Okay. Listen, it paid off later in my life. It sure it did.
所以当我读到这个开场白时，我想，我一定能搞定这个。然后我真的很担心他们会想要用电脑特效（CGI）。因为你当时说：“伙们，我能搞定。这不是CGI。”我想让每个人都知道。那是真正的奶酪球。我们拍摄时度过了最美好的时光。看起来确实如此。我被它的每一个瞬间逗乐了。珍娜，我也很擅长用嘴接食物。但这只是因为我手眼协调能力好，因为我有点像个运动健将。为什么我们从来没有互相扔过食物？我知道。我们这里有什么？我们能互相扔点东西吗？我们有一点麦片棒（granola bar）。我们有麦片棒和酒精。那行不通。好吧，下次我们带爆米花。我们可以拍下来。山姆要去厨房。
So don't feel sorry for me. I'm not feeling sorry for... I also saw tons of great movies and I have a great mind for the cinema. Yes. So I am really good at catching food in my mouth. I know. Also, my sister and I would throw popcorn at each other. Sure, sure.
哦，天哪。所以也许我们一会儿能拿到一些食物。我们确实花了一整个下午来拍摄这个。花时间最长的那个是三人互投。那里的……换个说法。我偏要按我想的表达。好吧，好吧。
So when I read this cold open, I was like, I'm going to nail this. And then I got really scared that they were going to want to CGI it. Because you were like, guys, I got this. It's not C. I want everyone to know. Those are real cheeseballs. We had the best time shooting this. It looks like it. I was just delighted by every moment of it. Jenna, I'm great at catching food in my mouth as well. But just because I have good hand-eye coordination because I'm a little bit of a sporto. Why have we never thrown food at one another? I know. What do we have in here? Can we throw something at each other? We have a little bit of granola bar. We have granola bar and alcohol. That's not going to work. Well, next time we're bringing popcorn. We can film that. Sam's going to the kitchen.
好吧……好吧，花时间最长的就是三人互投，正如你刚才所说，继续。你知道的，那个……是的，我知道。就像我们三个中每个人都把一个奶酪球扔进另一个人的嘴里，然后，哦。哦，天哪。
Oh, God. So maybe we'll get some food in a second. It did take us a whole afternoon to shoot this. And the one that took the longest was the three-way. Where... Just phrase that differently. I'm going to phrase it how I want to. Okay, okay.
我们有一些米脆饼（rice-crispy treats）。山姆给我们带来了米脆饼。这些会伤害我们的牙齿吗？它们是不含胶的吗？这会很痛。这就是我们所有的了。我是说，别用力扔。给你，拿一小块。
Well... Okay. The one that took the longest was the three-way, as you were saying, continue. You know, the one where... Yes, I know. Like, we're each throwing a cheeseball into a different person's mouth between the three of us. And, oh. Oh, my God.
好吧。好吧，准备好了吗？一，二，三。哦，那太糟糕了。那是什么抛投？哦，太糟糕了。好吧，等等，等等。
We have some rice-chrispy treats. Sam brought us rice-chispy treats. Will these hurt our teeth? Are they glue-free? This is going to hurt. That's all we have. I mean, don't throw them hard. Here, you go, put a little piece.
好吧，等一下。好吧，准备好了吗？哦，问题是当你试图扔它时，它会黏在你的拇指上。你扔得太低了。好吧。好吧。我们开始吧。
Okay. Okay, ready? Yeah. One, two, three. Oh, that was a terrible. What was that toss? Oh, it was a terrible. Okay, wait, wait.
她砸到我眼睛上了。哦，天哪。好吧，你想把球扔给我。等等，这些太黏了。这就是你的意思。你试着扔。你做不到。它根本离不开你的手。
Okay, hold on. Okay, ready? Yeah. Oh, the problem is it sticks to your thumb as you're trying to throw it. You're doing it so low. Okay. Okay. Here we go.
除了米脆饼棒，我们可能需要点别的。嘿，那真是一个很好的抛投。那根本不是好抛投。为什么我们要在这个播客里做视觉搞笑？好吧，停下。好吧，我们要停下了。好吧，我们成功了一个，伙们。我们成功了一个。
She gave me in the eye. Oh, my God. Okay, you're trying to throw to me. Wait, these are so sticky. That's what you mean. You try to throw it. You can't. It won't leave your foot.
好吧，引人入胜的内容。好吧，扔米脆饼有点困难。你刚才在谈论三人互投。哦，是的。那是难度最高的一个。你知道最后我们终于成功时你看到的那个反应吗？是的，因为你可能真的是由衷地兴奋。
We might need something other than Rice Krispy Treat bars. Hey, that was a really good toss. It wasn't a good toss. Why are we doing visual gags on our podcast? Okay, stop. Okay, we're going to stop. Okay, we got one, you guys. We got one.
那是真的。我想你能从我脸上的表情看出来。我知道我接住了我那份，然后我不得不看一眼他们是否真的接住了他们的，然后我们是真的感到兴奋。那是我们唯一一次把那个抛投做得完全正确。他们把它拍进镜头了。他们把它拍进镜头了。但我们为这个奶酪泡芙序列花了一整个下午。我们收到了来自亚伦·B（Aaron B.）的粉丝提问。最后，当奶酪球完美地落在帕姆的头发上时，那是剧本里写好的还是纯粹凭运气？那是纯粹凭运气。本来只是设定在打哈欠时，他们每个人朝我扔一个奶酪球。没错。
Okay. Riveting content. Well, throwing Rice Krispy Treats is a little difficult. You were talking about the three-way. Oh, yeah. That was the hardest one. You know that reaction that you see at the end when we finally make it? Yes, because you were probably genuinely excited.
我甚至不知道它卡在我的头发里了。太完美了，因为你直接看着镜头，以为你已经把另一个刷掉了，而且你头发上没有奶酪球了。是的。然后一个小家伙挂在你的头发上。毫无疑问，这是我在《办公室》拍过的最喜欢的序列之一。我觉得这让我、史蒂夫和比杰（BJ）紧密联系在了一起。我想是的。
That was real. think you can see the look on my face. I knew I caught mine and then I had to look and see if they really caught theirs and then we were genuinely excited. That was the only time we ever got that toss correct. And they got it on camera. They got it on camera. But we spent a whole afternoon on the cheese puff sequence. We got a fan question from Aaron B. At the end, when the cheese ball lands in Pam's hair so perfectly, was that in the script or just pure luck? That was pure luck. It was just supposed to be that each of those guys throw a cheeseball at me when I yawn. Right.
以一种真实的方式。是的。那是工作中非常非常开心的一天。好吧，现在这一集要开始了。
I didn't even know it was stuck in my hair. It's so perfect because you look directly at camera thinking you've brushed the other one off and your cheese ball free. Yes. And then one little dudes hanging in your hair. Without a doubt, this was one of my favorite sequences to shoot ever on the office. And I feel like it bonded me and Steve and BJ. I would think so.
开始时，吉姆、帕姆和安迪在休息室。我甚至不知道该给这个休息室的场景起个什么标题？“兜售痛苦”？我不知道。所以安迪正在向他们展示结婚蛋糕的照片。他正在放婚礼音乐。基本上，他和安吉拉的婚礼没办成，他正试图把为婚礼花钱买的东西转手卖出去。是的。他正试图让吉姆和帕姆买下他那场没办成的婚礼的这些元素。
In a real way. Yeah. It was a very, very fun day at work. Well, now the episode is going to say. start, Jim, Pam, and Andy are in the breakroom. I don't even know what to title this breakroom scene. Shopping over misery? I don't know. So Andy is showing them photos of wedding cakes. He's playing them wedding music. Basically, he's trying to sell off things he paid for for his wedding to Angela. Yeah. He's trying to get Pam and Jim to buy these elements from his not-havened wedding.
没办成的婚礼。是的。其中一样他放给他们听的是一首帕姆可以伴着走红毯的歌。由他的阿卡贝拉（Acapella）组合演唱。是的，这有点像《帕科贝尔》（Paco Bell）演变成《打电话给阿尔》（Call Me Al）的混合体。是的。我们应该听听吗？我想我们得听听。兰迪·科德雷（Randy Cordray）给我们发来了整首歌。
Filled wedding. Yeah. And one of the things, that he plays for them is a song that Pam could walk down the aisle to. By his acapella group. Yes, it's sort of a combination of Paco Bell that morphs into Call Me Al. Yes. Should we hear it? I think we need to. Randy Cordray sent us in the whole song.
我们听听吧。没错。嘟嘟，嘟，哒，哒，哒，哒，哒，哒，哒，哒，哒。没错。安迪告诉帕姆，她可以伴着这首歌走红毯。只要9000美元的低价，帕姆说对于一个连她或吉姆都没上过的大学的阿卡贝拉组合来说，这似乎有点贵。是的。
Let's hear it. That's right. Do do, do, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da. That's right. Andy tells Pam, she can walk down the aisle down the aisle to this song. for the low price of $9,000, which Pam says seems like a lot for an a cappella group from a college that neither her or Jim attended. Yeah.
等等，在我们继续之前，我只想让你们知道，我今天早上在厨房里播放了这首歌，简直在跳舞。埃德的吉他阿卡贝拉独奏永远、永远不会让人失望。如果你正经历倒霉的一天，听听埃德·海尔姆斯（Ed Helms）扮演的安迪发出“巴达”的声音，真的太棒了。你觉得有人真的伴着这个走过红毯吗？哦，我希望如此。
Wait, before we move on, I just want you guys to know, I played that this morning in my kitchen and literally was dancing. And Ed's guitar, acapella solo will never, ever disappoint. If you're having a day where you're down in the dumps, listen to Ed Helms. as Andy go, Bada, like, it's so good. Do you think anyone's ever actually walked down the aisle to this? Oh, I hope so.
我也是。哦，我希望如此。如果你伴着这个走红毯，你会标记《办公室女郎》播客吗？拜托了。我们收到了来自哈姆根·V（Harmgen V.）的粉丝提问。这首阿卡贝拉歌曲里所有的声音都是埃德·海尔姆斯一个人唱的吗？不。
Me too. Oh, I hope so. If you walk down the aisle to this, will you tag Office Ladies' Pod? Please. We got a fan question from Harmgen V. Did Ed Helms do all the voices in this Acapella song? No.
不，不是他。他召集了一群朋友来表演这段作品。他给约翰·迈克尔·希金斯（John Michael Higgins）打了电话，后者负责编曲和第一部分的独唱。你们认识他。他出演过所有克里斯托弗·格斯特（Christopher Guest）的电影。他还和文斯·沃恩（Vince Vaughn）以及詹妮弗·安妮斯顿（Jennifer Aniston）一起出演过那部电影《分手男女》（The Breakup），在片中他是一个名为“音符游侠”（The Tone Rangers）的阿卡贝拉组合的成员。但他以前也曾在《办公室》的一集中出现过，或者说他的声音出现过。没错。
No, he did not. He got together a group of his friends to perform this piece. He called John Michael Higgins, who did the arrangement and the solo voice in the first section. You guys know him. He's from all of the Christopher Guest movies. He was also in that movie The Breakup with Vince Fawn and Jennifer Aniston, where he's in an acapella group called The Tone Rangers. But he has also appeared, or his voice has appeared, on a previous episode of The Office. That's right.
不，他没有。他找了一群朋友来表演这首曲子。他打电话给约翰·迈克尔·希金斯，由他负责第一部分的编曲和独奏。你们认识他。他演过所有克里斯托弗·盖斯特的电影。他还演过那部由文斯·沃恩和詹妮弗·安妮斯顿主演的电影《分手男女》，在片中他加入了一个名叫“音调游侠”的阿卡贝拉合唱团。不过他或他的声音也曾出现在《办公室》之前的剧集里。没错。
You guys, he was in launch party. he and Ed saying, take a chance on me to Angela in that episode over speaker phone. Yes. So he did the lead vocals on this. Ed did that baseline. They recorded it in a studio, Universal Studios. Randy told us that they did this in three takes. Amazing. Amazing, Dr. Tibido. Amazing. Well, after this episode aired, they updated the Angela and Andy wedding website. They posted the whole song along with an advertisement for the Acapella Group for the wedding services for $9,000, just like Andy says in the scene. That's incredible.
伙计们，他参演了“新公司派对”。他和Ed在该集中通过免提电话给Angela唱了《Take a Chance on Me》。是的。所以他在这首歌里担任主唱。Ed负责贝斯。他们在环球影城录音室录制了这首歌。Randy告诉我们他们录了三次就完成了。太棒了，太棒了，蒂比多博士。太棒了。在这集播出后，他们更新了Angela和Andy的婚礼网站。他们发布了整首歌，以及一则阿卡贝拉合唱团为婚礼服务的广告，标价9000美元，就像Andy在剧中所说的那样。太不可思议了。
Well, next up, we see Dwight in a white, long-sleeve shirt. This scene was so funny to me. I thought Rain was so funny. The way he kept struggling in the long sleeve and saying how it was like affecting his attack readiness. He said it was like a straight jacket. Yeah. He's in the kitchen.
接下来，我们看到Dwight穿着一件白色长袖衬衫。这场戏对我和来说太搞笑了。我觉得Rain的表现太搞笑了。他一直跟那件长袖较劲的样子，说这影响了他的“攻击准备状态”。他说这感觉就像一件束腰外衣。没错。他在厨房里。
talking with Phyllis. I guess this is Charles's new dress code. Yeah. I had something happened to me when I was watching this scene. What? And I want to apologize for it in advance because it became a little bit of an obsession as I watched this episode. What? It didn't happen to me until my third time watching the episode. What happened? I became obsessed with what I believe was my observation that Dwight's sleeves are too short. Oh, Lord. They're too short. I think they're not long enough. And I found an article that breaks down exactly how long a man's dress shirt should fit. It has illustrations. Okay. So I created a photo side by side. You really did get obsessed. I mean, I spent way too long on this. Here is their illustration, Angela, of just right, too short, and then Rain's arm.
和Phyllis聊天。我猜这就是Charles的新着装规范吧。没错。我看着这场戏时，发生了一件怪事。什么事？我事先得道个歉，因为看这一集的时候，这事儿快成我的强迫症了。什么事？直到我第三遍看这一集时才注意到。发生什么了？我开始纠结一件事，我坚信Dwight的袖子太短了。天呐。袖子太短了。我觉得它们不够长。我还找到了一篇文章，详细分析了一件男士正装衬衫的袖子到底该有多长。上面还有插图。好吧。于是我做了一张对比图。你还真是魔怔了。我是说，我在这个上面花的时间太多了。Angela，这是他们给出的插图：刚刚好、太短，然后还有Rain的胳膊。
Oh. Now, I know that photo is not super convincing. I know that, but I tracked it through the whole episode and I have more evidence. Oh, my gosh, you and Dr. Tibado. Well, I actually, that's so funny that you bring this up because I became obsessed with Charles Miner's shirt. Oh. If you look at his shoulders, there's an extra stitching across his shoulder. And I think it's because his shoulders were so broad. I don't even understand why they would do that, except that maybe Idris had such broad shoulders. They had to have an extra stitch. I'm going to have to go look at that. I'm going to show it to you. I will find it because once I saw it, I couldn't unsee it. Okay, I have a picture of it. Jenna, please look at this extra stitch and pleat on his shoulder.
哦。我知道那张照片说服力不强。我知道，但我整集都在追踪它，我还有更多证据。哦，天呐，你和蒂比多博士真是绝配。其实，你提起这个太搞笑了，因为我开始纠结Charles Miner的衬衫。哦。如果你看他的肩膀，肩膀上有一道额外的缝线。我想这是因为他的肩膀太宽了。我甚至不明白他们为什么要这么做，除非Idris的肩膀实在太宽了。他们不得不加一道缝线。我得去看看那集。我这就给你看。我会找到它的，因为我一旦注意到，就再也忽视不了了。好吧，我有一张照片。Jenna，请看他肩膀上的这道额外缝线和褶裥。
What is that? What is that? See? Okay, okay. We did get a fan question for this scene from Evan T. and Pearl C. At 2 minutes, 49 seconds, when Dwight says his shirt is a straight jacket, and then he bumps into some wooden sticks and coffee mugs. Was that scripted or did that happen by accident? Because Phyllis's reaction is so genuine.
那是什么？那是什么？看到了吧？好吧，好吧。这场戏我们收到了来自Evan T.和Pearl C.的粉丝提问。在2分49秒时，当Dwight说他的衬衫像一件束腰外衣，然后他撞到了一些木棍和咖啡杯。那是剧本安排的还是意外发生的？因为Phyllis的反应太真实了。
I looked at the script. It was scripted that he would knock over the mugs while struggling. Mm-hmm. When that happens, that means there is a person off camera to reset all of those mugs. They will take a picture of what that little credenza looked like before the scene starts. And then after he knocks it all to the ground, they will meticulously reset each item so that when they're in the editing room, they can use any part of the top of the scene. That there's not like a mug over on the far side that used to be on. No bogies.
我看了剧本。剧本里就写了他在挣扎时会撞翻那些杯子。嗯哼。这种情况发生时，意味着现场有一个摄像机拍不到的工作人员来重置所有这些杯子。他们在场景开始前会给那个小矮柜拍一张照片。等他把所有东西都撞到地上后，他们会一丝不苟地把每件东西摆回原位，这样在剪辑室里时，他们就可以使用镜头前半部分的任何片段。不会出现本来在远处的杯子突然移位的情况。没有穿帮。
That's right. No random straw where it shouldn't be. I love Dwight's talking head, though. When he said when Michael was in charge, this place was like the Roman Empire and the Wild West and war-torn Poland and Poland. There was just a lot going on. So what you wore to work was the least of anybody's worries. And in that chaos, I soared. In this talking head, you can totally see his watch because his sleeves are too short.
没错。不会有不该出现的吸管。不过我喜欢Dwight的单人访谈。他说当Michael掌权时，这个地方就像罗马帝国、美国西部、饱受战争蹂躏的波兰……还有波兰。总之发生了太多事。所以你穿什么去上班是大家最不关心的问题。而在那种混乱中，我如鱼得水。在这个单人访谈里，你能清楚地看到他的手表，因为他的袖子太短了。
Okay, okay. I just want you to know. All right. Well, now Michael is going to meet Dwight. outside by the dumpster. Dwight tells Mike that Ed's... Mike. I don't know. All right. Dwight tells Michael that Ed's tires is looking to make a change.
好吧，好吧。我只是想让你知道。好吧，现在Michael要在垃圾箱外面见Dwight。Dwight告诉Mike，Ed's Tires（埃德轮胎）想要做出改变。
So Dwight is... He's helping him out. He is. He's giving him some intel. Inside info. And Michael gives him $6 for his trouble. Well, Dwight says he doesn't need compensation, but he does remind Michael that he owes him $10. From four years ago.
所以Dwight在……他在帮Mike。确实如此。他给Mike提供了一些内幕消息。内部情报。Michael给了他6美元作为感谢。好吧，Dwight说他不需要报酬，但他提醒Michael还欠他10美元。四年前的。
I know. I loved that. I had to know if that was scripted because I thought Steve was so funny when he was like, it's four years ago. Why won't you let that go? Was it scripted? It was. I also want you to know at three minutes and 30 seconds, you can clearly see Michael's shirt sleeves
我知道。我太喜欢这段了。我非得弄清楚这台词是不是剧本写的，因为我觉得Steve的表现太搞笑了，他说，那是四年前的事了。你怎么就放不下呢？是剧本写的吗？是的。我还想让你知道，在3分30秒时，你能清楚地看到Michael的衬衫袖子
coming out of his suit jacket, but you cannot see Dwight's. Jenna, you're on to something. You're on to something. Listen, Idris had broad shoulders and Rain's shirt was. It was too short. Too short. You believe me. I believe you.
从西装外套里露出来，但你看不到Dwight的。Jenna，你发现盲点了。你真的发现盲点了。听着，Idris肩膀很宽，而Rain的衬衫……确实太短了。太短了。你相信我了吧。我相信你。
Okay. Back inside, Andy is going to tell Jim that he's worried, you know? Pam bosses him around. He's really worried that their relationship maybe isn't so healthy. And he says, listen, I know a few things about love, horrible, terrible, awful things. Yeah, there's a lot to unpack here. Andy is projecting his own hurt onto Jim because Pam shot down this idea of using any of Andy's wedding stuff and he thinks Jim was bulldozed.
好吧。回到室内，Andy要告诉Jim他很担心，你知道的？Pam对指手画脚。他真的很担心他们的关系可能不太健康。他说，听着，我对爱情略知一二，那些可怕的、糟糕的、糟糕透顶的事情。是的，这里有很多值得剖析的地方。Andy把自己的伤痛投射到了Jim身上，因为Pam否决了使用任何Andy婚礼用品的想法，他认为Jim被强行架空了。
Right. So he's turned this into. into a whole story. Yeah, and Jim sees his opportunity now for a day long of pranking. Yeah, because I think Jim's a little offended. Well, it is ridiculous. Yeah, he's making a lot of assumptions. So now Michael is going to take this info that he got from Dwight. He's headed back to Michael Scott Paper Company, and he tells Pam to give Ed's tires a call. Yeah. Here's what she needs to say. She needs to say that Michael Scott Paper Company has fewer clients, so
对。所以他把这脑补成了一个完整的故事。是的，而Jim现在看到了整整一天恶作剧的机会。是的，因为我觉得Jim有点被冒犯了。好吧，这太荒谬了。是的，他做了很多假设。现在Michael要利用他从Dwight那里得到的情报。他正赶回迈克尔·斯科特纸业公司，他让Pam给Ed's Tires打个电话。没错。她需要这么说。她需要说迈克尔·斯科特纸业公司的客户更少，所以
they can spend more time with each of them, and also somehow mentioned she distrusts women. And he recommends she do it over Indian food. Pam's like, I'm not going to say that. Ryan's like, I can get there. That made me laugh out loud. This is a little foreshadowing for something that's going to come up later, which is that
他们可以花更多时间陪伴每一位客户，而且还要顺便提到她不信任女性。他建议她在吃印度菜的时候说这些。Pam说：“我才不说呢。”Ryan说：“我可以去。”这把我逗得哈哈大笑。这为后面要发生的事情做了一点铺垫，那就是
Michael takes kind of meticulous, detailed notes about each client. And he knows, well, he knows little details about each one. I feel like, When I saw Michael's Rolodex, Jenna, it reminded me of my note cards. Oh. Because I usually put a few words that mean something to me, right?
Michael对每个客户都做了细致入微的详细记录。他知道，好吧，他知道每个人的一些小细节。我觉得，当我看到Michael的转盘式名片盒时，Jenna，这让我想起了我的便签卡。哦。因为我通常只写几个对我有意义的词，对吧？
Mm-hmm. Now I put it all in a document, but if you look at my notes, I give myself words that only mean something to me. Look next to Jim's talking head. What does it say? Boo. Why does it say boo? You know what that means. I don't like Jim in this moment.
嗯哼。现在我都把它放在文档里了，但如果你看我的笔记，我写给自己的词只有我自己懂。看Jim单人访谈的旁边。上面写着什么？Boo（嘘）。为什么写着Boo？你知道那是什么意思。我当时不喜欢Jim。
I think he's being mean to Andy, so I wrote boo. And then right here, what is that? say trophy. That means something to me. We'll get to it. But I was like, oh my gosh, I'm Michael Scott. I have like a few keywords. Well, you know, in my early actor days when I would go to casting offices, I would come home and I had a little card file like a Rolodex where I would write down little notes about anything like that, like loves chocolate chip cookies so that the next time I went into that casting office, I could have something that might spark a moment of connection. You're like, hi, Tammy. Had any good chocolate chip cookies lately? Pretty much.
我觉得他对Andy不好，所以我写了boo。然后就在这儿，那是什么？写着trophy（奖杯）。这对我很有意义。我们一会儿会讲到。但我当时想，哦天呐，我就是Michael Scott。我只有几个关键词。好吧，你知道的，在我早年当演员去选角办公室的日子里，我回到家会有一个像转盘式名片盒那样的小卡片文件柜，我会把任何小细节写在上面，比如“喜欢巧克力豆曲奇”，这样下次我去那个选角办公室时，就能说点什么来擦出连接的火花。你就说，嗨，Tammy。最近吃过什么好吃的巧克力豆曲奇吗？差不多就是这样。
Yes. So casual. Yeah. Okay, so back to the scene. I have a little thing I spotted. At five minutes, nine seconds, there is a poster hanging in the background of the scene. It's over to the left of Michael's desk. It says, diversity. So that poster was made by Phil Shea using the hands of our hair and makeup crew. Yes, that is their hands and, like, I guess their arms, right? Yes. Yeah. So now Pam has a talking head. They've done their little chant. Their cheer. Their morning, you ugly cheer. Yeah, yeah. And she just said, listen, she's here. She's part of this now. That's right. And I had a little catch at five minutes and 16 seconds. What's up, background catch, queen? This is a on my face catch. Oh. Did you notice in this episode that I have a darker,
没错。太随性了。好吧，回到那个场景。我发现了一个小细节。在5分09秒时，场景背景中挂着一张海报。它在Michael办公桌的左侧。上面写着：“多元化”。那张海报是Phil Shea用我们发型和化妆组工作人员的手制作的。是的，那是他们的手，还有他们的胳膊，对吧？没错。是的。好了，现在Pam有了一段单人访谈。他们做完了他们的小口号。他们的加油打气。他们那个“早上好，你们这群丑八怪”的加油口号。对，对。她刚刚说，听着，她来了。她现在是这个团队的一员了。没错。我在5分16秒时抓到一个穿帮。背景穿帮女王，怎么说？这是一个我脸上的穿帮。哦。你注意到这一集里我的嘴唇颜色更深、
pigmented lip and eye shadow. It's a much richer color. No, I did not notice. Oh my gosh. Okay. I noticed because this was a huge thing. Listen, when you had dark nail polish out of nowhere, I noticed. I know. Your lipstick I didn't quite notice. We usually alternated between two neutral lip shades, but my makeup artist Laverne, she said, I really think we could go a little bolder for Pam. She made her first sale last week. Yeah, she's got our blazer. Yeah. Yeah. So how can we continue to tell the story of her growing confidence? So we went with a bolder lip. I like it. Thank you. Our next scene is Charles and Dwight. They're in Charles's office. Note his shoulders, please. Also, please note that Rain's entire watch is exposed because his sleeves are too short. Okay. Five minutes, 39 seconds. All right. So basically, Charles wants to know if Dwight is happy at the company, you know, and he invites him out. to drinks.
唇彩和眼影更浓了吗？这是一种浓郁得多的颜色。不，我没注意到。哦，天呐。好吧。我注意到了，因为这是一件大事。听着，当你的指甲油无缘无故变成深色时，我都注意到了。我知道。你的口红我倒是没怎么注意。我们通常在两个中性唇色之间切换，但我的化妆师Laverne说：“我真的觉得Pam可以涂得更大胆一点。”她上周完成了第一笔交易。对，她穿上了西装外套。对。那么我们如何继续讲述她自信心增长的故事呢？所以我们选了更大胆的唇色。我喜欢。谢谢。下一个场景是Charles和Dwight。他们在Charles的办公室里。请注意他的肩膀。另外，请注意Rain的手表完全露出来了，因为他的袖子太短了。好吧。5分39秒。好了。基本上，Charles想知道Dwight在公司过得开不开心，你知道的，他邀请Dwight下班后去喝酒。
Mm-hmm. So in the background of the scene, you can see Jim. Jenna, John has angled his computer because he's clearly like surfing the internet or checking email or something. So while I was watching the scene, the first time I just watched it just to watch it, then I was like, wait a second. John's doing email in the background and the way back. This scene also has a line I love when Charles says to Dwight, you're so focused. And Dwight says, like a wolf. Thank you.
嗯哼。在这个场景的背景中，你能看到Jim。Jenna，John把他的电脑转了个角度，因为他显然在网上冲浪或者查邮件什么的。所以当我看着这个场景时，第一遍我只是纯粹地看，然后我想，等一下。John在背景里查邮件，就在最远处。这个场景里还有一句我特别喜欢的台词，当Charles对Dwight说：“你太专注了。”Dwight说：“像一头狼一样。”谢谢。
Well, Rain was asked in an interview what he thought drinks between Dwight and Charles might entail. Yeah? And this was his answer. He said, probably Charles getting really bored after about eight minutes and making up an excuse to leave. He was also asked about his decision to choose Dunder Mifflin over Michael Scott Paper Company. What did he say? He said, Dwight is loyal to whoever values loyalty the most. and in this case, Dunder Mifflin honors loyalty with an actual paycheck.
好吧，Rain在一次采访中被问到，他觉得Dwight和Charles一起去喝酒会发生什么。是吗？他的回答是这样的。他说，大概Charles在大约八分钟后就会觉得无聊透顶，然后找借口离开。他还被问到为什么选择邓德·米夫林而不是迈克尔·斯科特纸业公司。他怎么说？他说，Dwight对谁最看重忠诚，就效忠于谁，在这种情况下，邓德·米夫林用实实在在的薪水来兑现忠诚。
And that is why he chose Dunder Mifflin. I also want to point out in this scene that Charles is still drinking out of his Sattacoys steel insulated coffee mug. And I have to say, I think it's a betrayal. You're out of the steel business, Charles. Let it go. Get a Dunder Mifflin insulated mug already. Yeah.
这就是他选择邓德·米夫林的原因。我还要指出的是，在这个场景中，Charles仍然在用他的Satticoys钢铁保温咖啡杯。我必须说，我觉得这是一种背叛。你已经不在钢铁行业了，Charles。放手吧。快去买个邓德·米夫林的保温杯吧。对啊。
What is your attachment to your Satticoys steel mug? You know corporate gave him a mug, but he's not used to. it. Why not? That's a choice. That's what I'm saying. Yeah. I think Michael knows this guy. He's a steel man at heart. Right. This next scene is amazing. Michael calls Dwight to ask about Dunner Mifflin's pricing for Ed's tires. He wants to undercut them. Right. And this is when Dwight's internal conflict begins. Yeah, he starts to waffle. Well, because Charles has invited him to drinks. Michael never invited him to drinks. I know. So he tells Michael something's come up. And Michael's like, oh my gosh, is it Mo's? Did you cover up the well? What is that backstory? I don't know. Has Moes fallen in the well? Of course he has. He's probably fallen and been gone for like two days and then they find him in the well. I love comedy like that. It's just on there and then it goes away. Yeah, you just throw it away.
你对你的Satticoys钢铁杯到底有什么执念？你知道公司发给他一个杯子了，但他不习惯。为什么不习惯？那是个人选择。这就是我想说的。对。我觉得Michael很了解这家伙。他骨子里是个钢铁男儿。没错。下一个场景太棒了。Michael打电话给Dwight询问邓德·米夫林针对Ed's Tires的报价。他想压低他们的价格。没错。就在这时，Dwight内心的冲突开始了。是的，他开始动摇了。因为Charles邀请他去喝酒。Michael从来没邀请他去喝酒。我知道。所以他告诉Michael有点急事。Michael就说：哦，天呐，是Moose（莫斯）的事吗？你把水井盖好了吗？那是什么背景故事？我不知道。Moose掉进井里了吗？他肯定掉下去了。他大概掉下去失踪了两天，然后他们才在井里找到他。我就喜欢这种喜剧效果。随口一说，然后就过去了。对，随口抛个梗。
Michael's not getting it. He's not. Dwight starts kind of talking in code. He's kind of like things are changing fast and, you know. There's a cool new guy. And I don't think he'd like it if I helped even my personal hero. And Michael's like, what are you talking about? What are you talking about? So Pam and Ryan are like have to write on a notepad to help Michael understand what Dwight is saying. And then Steve is Michael reads the notepad. All the expressions that come over Steve's face as Michael figures this out.
Michael没听懂。他根本没懂。Dwight开始打哑谜。他差不多是在说，情况变化很快，你知道的。来了一个很酷的新人。而且如果我帮了我的个人英雄，我猜他不会高兴的。Michael就说：你在说什么？你在说什么啊？所以Pam和Ryan不得不写在记事本上帮Michael理解Dwight在说什么。然后Steve饰演的Michael看着记事本。当Michael想通时，Steve脸上的各种表情。
I was blown away. I said give Steve all of the awards. And that's why I drew a trophy. Seriously, though, this is an amazing performance. It's so subtle and nuanced. And Steve, I loved every single thing you did as Michael being clueless and then not believing the note they're holding up, but then figuring it out and then being like, oh, my God, and then being betrayed, like all of it.
我简直惊呆了。我说，把所有的奖项都颁给Steve。这就是为什么我画了一个奖杯。说真的，这是一场精彩绝伦的表演。既含蓄又微妙。Steve，我太喜欢你饰演Michael时表现出的那种一无所知、不相信他们举着的纸条、然后突然想通、接着露出“哦，天呐”、然后感觉自己被背叛的每一个细节，所有这些。
It is really hard to play realization as an actor. Yeah. Because you know the information. You had to memorize it. You had to read the script. You know where the scene is going. Yes. And so to play all of that, it is like one of the hardest things to do as an actor.
作为演员，要演出“顿悟”的瞬间真的很难。因为你已经知道了这些信息。你必须背熟台词。你必须读过剧本。你知道剧情发展的方向。是的。所以要把这一切演出来，可以说是演员最难做到的事情之一。
And then to do it comedically, amazing. Amazing. We got a fan question about this scene from Kelton O who said, how is it that Pam and Ryan can hear both sides of this phone call? Yeah. They seem to hear Dwight so clearly through the phone. Well, this is very funny, Kelton, because. Rain was actually right off camera.
而且还要用喜剧的方式演出来，太惊艳了。太惊艳了。我们收到了Kelton O.关于这个场景的粉丝提问，他说，为什么Pam和Ryan能听到这通电话的两头？是的。他们隔着电话听Dwight的声音听得那么清楚。好吧，Kelton，这非常搞笑，因为。Rain其实就在镜头外。
Yeah. Doing his side of the phone call. We could totally hear him. Rain actually had to come into work that day. He did not have anything else to shoot. All he did was stand off camera and read his side of the phone call. It's actually a thing. It's called doing off camera work.
没错。在念他那边的电话台词。我们能听得清清楚楚。Rain那天其实不得不来上班。他没有别的戏要拍。他所做的就是站在镜头外，念出他那边的台词。这其实很常见。这叫作“画外音工作”。
And that is often how different sides of a phone call are done. We did not have the capability to like call into that office. Right. Like we did upstairs. Because it was a closet and a faky phone. Yes. I thought I could see how they were cheating it a little because Michael is kind of holding the phone out. So you would assume if he had the volume pretty high up.
电话的两头通常就是这样完成的。我们没有那种可以直接拨进那个办公室的技术。就像我们在楼上做的那样。因为那是个杂物间，用的是假电话。是的。我当时觉得我能看出他们是怎么作弊的，因为Michael差不多是把电话拿得离耳朵有点远。所以你会假设如果他把音量开得相当高的话。
It's a tiny room that you guys could probably hear. We also had a fan catch from Maya R. Who said this, Angela? What? This went right to my heart. She said, I noticed a paper pro stapler on Pam and Ryan's table. And my mom actually works for the company. that sells these staplers, it originated in Pennsylvania before merging with Boss Stitch.
那是个小房间，你们俩可能真的能听到。我们还收到了来自Maya R.的粉丝穿帮。她是这样说的，Angela！什么？这话直接戳中了我的心。她说，我注意到Pam和Ryan的桌子上放了一个Paper Pro订书机。我妈妈其实就在这家出售订书机的公司工作，它最初发源于宾夕法尼亚州，后来与Bostitch合并了。
Could this be why the stapler was used in this episode? I don't know, Maya, but I brought my Paper Pro stapler today. You did? I got to try it out. All right. I brought champagne. Jenna brought a stapler. Here it is. Now watch. Do I get to do it?
这会不会就是这一集里使用这款订书机的原因？我不知道，Maya，但我今天把我的Paper Pro订书机带来了。真的吗？我得试试。好吧。我带了香槟。Jenna带了订书机。就是这个。现在看好了。轮到我试了吗？
Yes. I am going to do it with a single finger. Wait, wait, here. Now, I wish I'd brought a regular stapler. I had meant to bring a regular stapler. I'm sure there is one. Okay, ready? Watch this.
是的。我只用一根手指就能搞定。等等，等等，给你。现在，我真希望自己带的是个普通订书机。我本来是想带个普通订书机的。我相信肯定有一个。好了，准备好了吗？看这个。
Can you hear the clicking mechanism? Listen to the air pressure. I heard that. It is amazing. Try it. Okay, I'm going to try it. Staples something. I'm a staple something.
你能听到咔哒的机械声吗？听听这个气压。我听到了。太神奇了。你试试。好吧，我要试试。订点东西。我来订点东西。
It's not a regular stapler where you get a k-junk. It's like, ch. Okay, that's very hard. You can do it with one finger. Okay, ready? Mm-hmm. Oh, yes.
它不像那种“咔哒”一声的普通订书机。它的声音是，ch。好吧，这真的很难。你用一根手指就能做到。好了，准备好了吗？嗯哼。哦，是的。
I see what you're talking about. There's like a spring or something. I say, shut up. I bought you a paper pro stapler. Yay! Sam, I have one for you. Oh, my God. Cassie, I have one for you.
我懂你说的意思了。里面好像有弹簧之类的东西。我说，闭嘴吧。我给你买了个Paper Pro订书机。耶！Pam，我也有一个送给你。哦，天呐。Cassie，我也有一个送给你。
Oh, my gosh. Thank you. You need to have it. Here's the last thing I'll say about the stapler, I think. I don't think you're done talking about it. Don't make that promise. Sometimes when we do these acting jobs, You acquire a new skill maybe that you didn't have before.
哦，天呐。谢谢你。你必须拥有一个。关于订书机，我最后要说的一点是，我觉得。我不觉得你已经说够了。别向我保证这个。有时候当我们做这些表演工作时，你会掌握一门以前可能不会的新技能。
When I did Blades of Glory, I had to train with a ice skating coach. I learned how to be quite a good ice skater. Sure. When I did walk hard, I took a little bit of horse riding lessons. It's like a fun perk. You get these skills. Right. Sometimes you get introduced to an item.
当我拍《冰刀双人组》时，我不得不跟花样滑冰教练一起训练。我学会了如何成为一个相当不错的滑冰运动员。确实。当我拍《永不止步》时，我上了一点骑马课。这就像是一个有趣的额外福利。你掌握了这些技能。没错。有时候你会接触到某样东西。
I remember when I did splitting up together, there was just this amazing set of pajamas that I'd never heard of before. And after wearing them on the show, I bought three pairs. I am now a lifelong fan of SaaS shoes. Exactly. That is what this paper pro stapler was for me. And it was all thanks to Michael Scott Paper Company. Well, there you go. Before we go to break, I have one more thing to point out about this scene.
我记得当我拍《分道扬镳》时，剧组有一套我以前从未听说过的神奇睡衣。在节目中穿过之后，我买了三套。我如今成了SaaS鞋的终身粉丝。没错。这个Paper Pro订书机对我就有这种意义。这一切都要感谢迈克尔·斯科特纸业公司。好吧，就是这样。在我们进入广告时间之前，我还有一件事要指出。
It's at six minutes, 11 seconds. It is a very good shot of our second goldfish. Oh, yeah. Our first goldfish was orange. That goldfish is gone. This week. it is a red, orange, white, and black spotted fish. And we got a letter from Jess L. who said,
是在6分11秒。这是一个非常清晰的镜头，拍到了我们的第二条金鱼。哦，对。我们的第一条金鱼是橙色的。那条金鱼已经不在了。这周。它变成了一条红、橙、白、黑相间的花斑鱼。我们收到了一封来自Jess L.的信，她说，
I spent 10 years working in pet stores as an aquatic specialist, and pet industry employees have been wondering for years whether or not the changing of the goldfish were a planned bit. Now, we said last week it was. Yeah. But she goes on to say, anyone who works in fish departments knows goldfish deaths are common. And a lot of us in the industry assume that the props people chose to make a bit out of the situation. And just so you know, goldfish should have about 10 gallons of water per fish and it requires filtration to truly thrive in captivity.
我在宠物店当了10年水族专家，宠物行业的员工多年来一直想知道更换金鱼是不是剧组蓄意安排的烂梗。好吧，我们上周说过，是的。但她接着说，任何在鱼类部门工作过的人都知道金鱼死亡很常见。我们行业里的很多人都猜测是道具组利用这种情况搞了个梗。而且你们要知道，金鱼每条鱼大约需要10加仑水，并且需要过滤才能在人工饲养中真正茁壮成长。
She, I think, wanted us to know that because any of you out there with goldfish trying to keep them alive, that could really help. I think that's solid advice. All right, that's all I got. Well, I have something delicious coming up with Jim and Andy that I can't wait to share. Ooh. It just brought me so much joy. And why don't we take a break and I'll come back with that. I can't wait.
她大概是想让我们知道这一点，因为你们这些养金鱼却在努力让它们活着的人，这真的能帮到忙。我觉得这是个中肯的建议。好吧，我说的就这些。好吧，接下来我和Jim以及Andy之间有一段非常有趣的互动，我迫不及待想分享。哦。这给我带来了太多的快乐。要不我们休息一下，我回来再讲。我等不及了。
We are back. I love this Jim and Andy scene. Jim is going to approach Andy and he's going to say, hey, Andy, you know what? I've been thinking about what you said. Andy's like, noish. And Jim's like, I just don't know if I can do it. Andy's like, that's interesting because I hear what you're saying is that you want to do it, which means you can do it. Believe me, I broke up with Angela and I'm like the happiest guy ever.
我们回来了。我太喜欢Jim和Andy的这段戏了。Jim走向Andy说：“嘿，Andy，你知道吗？我一直在想你之前说的话。”Andy说：“差不多吧。”Jim说：“我只是不知道我能不能做到。”Andy说：“这就很有意思了，因为我听出你的意思是你想做，这就意味着你能做到。相信我，我和Angela分手了，我现在是世界上最快乐的人。”
I mean, I am so happy. I am so happy. Like, total freedom, you know. And Jim says, it's just that Pam gets me through the day. Like, I really rely on her. I'm pretty emotionally needy. And Andy says, and you know what? I'm here for you. Let me be your traveling pants.
我是说，我太快乐了。我太快乐了。就像获得了完全的自由，你知道的。Jim说：“只是Pam陪我度过了每一天。我真的很依赖她。我在情感上挺需要别人的。”Andy说：“你知道吗？我支持你。让我来当你的‘牛仔裤的夏天’吧。”
Mm-hmm. That was all scripted. And in the script, it says that Jim and Andy do a little knuckles bump. Yeah. And they just simply say knuckles. And that's the end of the scene. Okay. Well, in our version, Jim goes to give the knuckles and Andy leans in and puts his cheek in front of the knuckles.
嗯哼。这些全都是剧本里写的。剧本上说Jim和Andy轻轻碰了下拳。没错。然后他们只说了一个词：“碰拳”。戏就结束了。好吧。但在我们的版本里，Jim伸出拳头去碰拳，而Andy却把脸凑了过来，把脸颊挡在拳头前面。
And Jim just starts to laugh. And he's like, dude, you know I meant knuckles. And he's like, yeah, knuckles. All right. So Ed just improvised that. That whole moment. Go to eight minutes, 26 seconds. John is laughing at Ed because he didn't know Ed was going to lean his face into the knuckle bump.
Jim直接笑场了。他说：“老兄，你知道我刚才的意思是碰拳吧。”Andy说：“对啊，碰拳。”好吧。所以Ed是即兴发挥的。整段都是即兴的。转到8分26秒。John在笑Ed，因为他根本不知道Ed会把脸凑过来碰拳。
And it made it in. And it just brought me joy because I just see these two guys and I see their friendship at 8 minutes, 26 seconds. Well, when Andy said, I'll be your traveling pants, that made me think of our director, Ken Kwapis, who directed the sisterhood of the traveling pants. Yes. And you and I went together to go see it. I remember watching that movie because there was this really. Yes. Handsome. It made us want to go to Greece. Remember after that movie? We're like, we should go to Greece. We really should. We should still go to Greece. We should. Well, now we have another scene out by the dumpster. Michael is going to meet Dwight again, but guess what? It's a setup. Oh, yeah. Charles is there. And Charles is going to tell Michael to leave Dunder Mifflin alone and to stop pestering Dwight for info. I have two things to point out about this scene. What are they? The first one is from the shooting draft script, and it's something that did not make it in the episode, and I really wish it had. Michael immediately notices Dwight's shirt.
而且这个镜头还被剪进正片了。这给我带来了快乐，因为我看着这两个家伙，看到了他们之间的友谊，在8分26秒。当Andy说“我来当你的牛仔裤的夏天”时，这让我想起了我们的导演Ken Kwapis，他执导了《牛仔裤的夏天》。没错。你和我一起去看的那部电影。我记得看那部电影是因为里面有一个非常。帅气。这让我们想去希腊。还记得看完那部电影之后吗？我们说：“我们应该去希腊。”我们真的应该去。我们还是应该去希腊。我们应该去的。好吧，现在我们在垃圾箱外面还有一场戏。Michael又要去见Dwight了，但你猜怎么着？这是一个局。哦，对。Charles也在。Charles警告Michael不要再纠缠邓德·米夫林，不要再为打听消息而骚扰Dwight。关于这场戏我有两点要指出。是什么？第一点来自拍摄初稿剧本，这是没有被剪进正片里的一段，我真的很希望当时能播出来。Michael一眼就注意到了Dwight的衬衫。
Yeah. Yeah. And he says, why are you dressed like that? And he turns to Charles and goes, are you making him wear that? What about his attack readiness? You fool. Oh, what a great callback. I know.
没错。他说：“你穿成这样干嘛？”然后他转向Charles说：“是你逼他穿成这样的吗？那他的攻击准备状态怎么办？你个笨蛋。”哦，多棒的前后呼应啊。我知道。
I thought it was so sweet that Michael was like, oh, yeah, Dwight has to wear a short sleeve so he can attack someone. Yes. I had asked James Carey if he would send me the call sheets for this episode. There were a few things I wanted to investigate. And I noticed that there was a note for this scene that said, we need to shoot this scene at 3.30 p.m. with three exclamation points. I asked Randy about this. Why? Yeah.
我觉得Michael那种反应太可爱了，他说：“哦，对，Dwight必须穿短袖，这样才能攻击别人。”是的。我曾问过James Carey能否把这一集的通告单发给我。有几件事我想调查一下。我注意到这场戏的备注上写着：“我们需要在下午3点30分拍摄这场戏”，后面还有三个惊叹号。我问过Randy为什么要这样。为什么？
Did Idris have to go somewhere? Yeah. Why 3.30? What was it? Yeah. He said it was the light. Ah. That this section of the alleyway was. on the far side of stage two, and it was kind of a deep canyon, he said, between the stage and the
难道Idris有事要走吗？对。为什么非得是3点30分？有什么说法？他说是因为光线。啊。小巷子的这一段是。在2号摄影棚的远端，他形容这是一个很深的峡谷，位于摄影棚和
hedges. It was on the far side of the warehouse, where we filmed the warehouse scenes. Yes. And he said it's really, really difficult to hide lights there. So you have to use natural light. And if you shoot it too early or too late, the sun is blocked by the hedges or by the warehouse. But I guess at 3.30, the angle is just right. So I guess at 3.30 is when we had our bird funeral? It must have been. 3.30 in the alley. I am thinking of how many scenes I had in that alley. That's where Angela and Dwight would meet. And she gave him sprinkles list of ointments and things like that. And years later, that's where I say jazz is stupid. So it's all 3.30. You can set your watch by it. Well, Michael's going to return to Michael Scott Paper Company. and he's going to try to tell them what happened.
树篱之间。它在仓库的远端，也就是我们拍摄仓库戏的地方。没错。他说要在那里藏灯光真的、真的很难。所以你必须利用自然光。如果你拍得太早或太晚，太阳就会被树篱或仓库挡住。但我想在3点30分，角度刚好合适。所以我想我们在3点30分举行了小鸟葬礼？一定是那个时间。下午3点30分在小巷里。我在想我在那个小巷里拍了多少场戏。那是Angela和Dwight约会的地方。她给了他Sprinkles的药膏清单之类的东西。多年以后，我在那里说爵士乐太蠢了。所以全都是在3点30分。你都可以根据这个来对表了。好吧，Michael要回迈克尔·斯科特纸业公司了。
And basically, he got a pee-filled water balloon thrown in his face. That's what he tells Pam and Ryan. Yes. I mean, they're like, clearly at some point in his life that actually happened, right? Must have. Oh, that's terrible. Well, they have to really decipher what that means. Mm-hmm.
他要试图告诉大家发生了什么。
So they can figure out what the heck is happening. Well, Michael's going to call Dwight. And he says, I'm going to steal all your clients, and I'm going to kill them in front of you. Yeah. I'm going to come at you and I'm going to come at you hard. And then both Dwight and Michael try to call Dwight's biggest client, The Whale, Mr. Schofeld, from Harper Collins. Harper Collins, who is publishing our book Office BFF? I know. Jenna, when I rewatch this, I was like, oh my gosh, this is synchronicity. Does this mean our book is going to be printed on Dunder Mifflin paper? What? That would be.
基本上，他脸上被扔了一个装满尿的水球。这就是他告诉Pam和Ryan的。没错。我是说，他们心想，他在人生的某个阶段确实经历过这种事吧？肯定是。哦，太糟糕了。好吧，他们不得不仔细揣摩这句话到底是什么意思。嗯哼。
amazing. I mean, they're a client, right? Our book is being published, like, on the East Coast. It was really cool, though, because of all the book publishers out there, we're with Harper Collins, and then Dwight says Harper Collins, and I was like, oh, my God. I know. Should we give a book update, by the way? I want everyone to know, we made it through that crazy document. I figured it out. Angela figured it out. That's saying something. Listen, she didn't think she was going to figure it out. And I said you can do it. I really had a moment, you guys, like for real, where I was like, this isn't going to happen. And I'm sorry?
这样他们才能弄清楚到底发生了什么鬼。好吧，Michael要打电话给Dwight。他说：“我要抢走你所有的客户，我要当着你的面让他们破产。”没错。我要针对你，我要狠狠地针对你。然后Dwight和Michael都试图给Dwight最大的客户、大客户——来自Harper Collins的Schofield先生打电话。Harper Collins，那不就是出版我们的书《Office BFFs》的出版社吗？我知道。Jenna，当我重新看这一集时，我心想：哦，天呐，这就是心灵感应。这是否意味着我们的书要用邓德·米夫林的纸来印刷？什么？那可就
I can't do it. But then I did it. You did it. I made myself a little cheat sheet that I kept by my computer. Oh, yeah. I mean, listen, I hope I did it. I know. We haven't gotten any feedback on it yet.
太厉害了。我是说，他们是客户，对吧？我们的书马上就要出版了，就在东海岸。不过真的很酷，在所有的图书出版商中，我们偏偏签了Harper Collins，然后Dwight说出了Harper Collins，当时我就想：哦，天呐。我知道。顺便问一句，我们要不要更新一下书的进展？我想让大家知道，我们熬过了那个疯狂的文档。我把它搞定了。Angela把它搞定了。这可真不容易。听着，她一开始觉得她自己根本搞不定。我说你行的。我当时真的有一刻，伙计们，说实话，我觉得：“这根本弄不完。”对不起。
Maybe we're going to get like a note back that was like, well, way to go, ladies. You completely effed it up. I know. And, okay, so we have two more rounds of that. And then the book is like locked and it goes to the printer. Oh, Lordy. So yeah. Can't make any changes.
我做不到。但最后我还是做到了。你做到了。我给自己做了一份小抄，一直放在电脑旁边。哦，对。我是说，听着，希望我真的做对了。我知道。我们还没收到任何反馈呢。
I know. It's coming up. I showed it to my kids. Yeah? I showed them the photo layout. And they were like, oh my gosh, because it's finally a book. Do you know what I mean? It's not just like you and I turning in all these pages.
也许我们会收到一条回复说：“干得好啊，女士们。你们把排版彻底搞砸了。”我知道。而且，好吧，我们还有最后两轮审核。然后这本书就彻底定稿，送去印刷了。哦，天呐。所以，是的。不能再做任何修改了。
Yes. It looks like a book. It looks like a book. It looks like a book. It looks like a book. I showed it to Lee. Uh-huh. And I said, oh, do you want to see how the photos kind of lay out?
我知道。马上就要出版了。我把排版给我的孩子们看了。是吗？我给他们看了照片布局。他们当时说：“哦，天呐”，因为这终于像一本书了。你知道我的意思吗？这不仅仅是你和我交上去的那些纸。
And I thought he would look at it. Honestly, I thought he would like... Just glance at it. Yeah, then he would be like, oh my God, it looks cool. He went through every single page. But like he was compelled to. He was like, this is amazing. Aw.
没错。它看起来像本书了。它看起来像本书。它看起来像本书。它看起来像本书。我把它给Lee看了。嗯哼。我说：“哦，你想看看照片是怎么排版的吗？”
He was like... Dr. Tibido, Lee said amazing. Lee said amazing. He said, it's so personal. It's, wow. He's like these pictures. He already knew the stories. Right.
我以为他会看。老实说，我以为他会……只是扫一眼。对，然后他会说：“哦，天呐，看起来挺酷。”结果他一页一页仔仔细细地看完了。就像他被深深吸引了一样。他当时说：“这太棒了。”啊。
And he just was like, people are are going to love this. That's what he said. And it meant so much to me because we've, you know, sometimes you make something in a bubble and you don't know. Right. We like it. We love it. So to me that, oh, that was such a confidence boost. Oh, yeah. That's what I needed to try to figure out the formatting document. I needed that boost. I needed a glass of wine. Well, let's get back to the episode. Michael does finally get Mr. Schofield on the phone by promising him a set of tickets to the Penguins game. The Wilkesbury Penguins game. Look what I'm wearing.
他说……蒂比多博士，Lee说太棒了。Lee说太棒了。他说：“这太有个人特色了。太惊艳了。”他说这些照片。他本来就知道这些故事。没错。然后他就说：“人们一定会爱死这本书的。”他是这么说的。这对我的意义太重大了，因为我们，你知道的，有时候你在一个封闭的环境里创作，你根本不知道结果会怎样。没错。我们自己很喜欢。我们爱不释手。所以对我来说，哦，这简直是一剂巨大的强心针。哦，是的。我正需要这个来试着搞定排版文档。我需要这种信心。我需要来杯葡萄酒。好吧，让我们回到这一集。Michael最终通过承诺赠送一套企鹅队比赛的门票，成功把Schofield先生约到了电话上。威尔克斯巴里企鹅队的比赛。看看我穿的什么。
And Angela is wearing her very own personal Wilkesbury Penguins hockey jersey with her name on the back. Yeah, I'm number one, Kinsey. So in 2007, I went to the office convention with Craig Robinson, Kate Flannery, and Brian Baumgartner. And we all went to a Wilkesbury Penguins game. We got to go out on the ice. We got to meet Tucks, their mascot. and we all got a jersey. I've kept it all these years. And I wore it today for our 100th episode. That is so cool. Here's our picture, Jenna. I'll show you. Look at us on the ice.
而Angela穿着她自己专属的威尔克斯巴里企鹅队冰球球衣，背面印着她的名字。对，我是头号球迷，Kinsey。所以在2007年，我和Craig Robinson、Kate Flannery还有Brian Baumgartner一起去参加了办公室粉丝见面会。我们全都去看了威尔克斯巴里企鹅队的比赛。我们甚至走到了冰场上。我们见到了他们的吉祥物Tux。我们每个人都得到了一件球衣。这些年我都一直留着。为了我们的第100期节目，我今天把它穿上了。太酷了。这是我们的照片，Jenna。我给你看。看我们在冰场上。
Oh my gosh. Is that cool? It was such a fun day. Were you nervous when you were walking on the ice? I was. Because you just wear your regular shoes. I was. And I had these little boots on. And I was like, Dear Lord, please don't let me bust my butt in front of all these people. Did they have little carpets down or no? At the beginning. But then we walked all the way to the center. And there was no more carpet. it. Yes. I got to go to the All-Stars game in St. Louis. Oh, so cool. And I got to be like a coach on the sideline. It was really fun, yes. And then at the end, I had to walk out on the ice. Yeah. And I was so nervous that I was going to fall. And David Pasternak from the Boston Bruins, he came over and he, like, gave me his arm. And it was like a big fan girl moment for me.
哦，天呐。酷不酷？那天太有趣了。你走在冰上的时候紧张吗？我很紧张。因为你穿的是普通的鞋子。我很紧张。我还穿着那种小靴子。我当时想：“天呐，求求你千万别让我当着这么多人的面摔个狗吃屎。”他们有铺小地毯吗？没有吗？在开始的时候有。但后来我们一路走到冰场中央。就没有地毯了。没错。我有幸去圣路易斯参加了全明星赛。哦，太酷了。我还当了场边教练。真的非常有趣，是的。然后到最后，我不得不走到冰场上去。是的。我当时紧张得要命，生怕自己摔倒。来自波士顿棕熊队的David Pasternak走过来，他主动把胳膊借给我扶着，对我来说这真是一个大型追星现场。
Well, I held Kate Flannery's arm. Who did the penguins play that day? Oh, they played the Albany River Rats. Oh. Yeah. I just love hockey. I can't say it more times. I have to say it was a really fun time.
好吧，我当时扶的是Kate Flannery的胳膊。企鹅队那天跟谁比赛来着？哦，他们和奥尔巴尼河鼠队比赛。哦。我太喜欢冰球了。怎么表达都不嫌多。我必须说，那真是一段非常快乐的时光。
Well, Michael's thing with the tickets is going to work because Dwight is going to get a call for Mr. Schofield and he's going to say he's leaning toward Michael Scott paper company. So Dwight calls Michael. He's like, I will agree to meet you 100 feet from our original meeting place. They're not going to meet at the same. their same secret location. No, no, no. Mix it up, guys. 100 feet away at high noon. Yes. And Michael tells Dwight to walk 100 feet toward the sun. But it's right above you. It's not possible. Dwight's clearly confused. I have a whole thing about Dwight's undies. Oh, yes. We're going to see
好吧，Michael用门票换来的局成功了，因为Dwight接到了Schofield先生的电话，对方说他更倾向于迈克尔·斯科特纸业公司。于是Dwight打电话给Michael。他说：“我同意在距离我们最初见面地点100英尺远的地方见面。”他们不打算在同一个地点见面了。同一个秘密地点。不，不，不。换个地方嘛，伙计们。在正午时分，距离100英尺远的地方见。是的。然后Michael让Dwight顶着太阳走100英尺。但太阳就在你头顶上方啊。这根本不可能。Dwight显然被搞糊涂了。我有一大堆关于Dwight内裤的八卦要讲。哦，是的。我们要看到
some green undies on Dwight. Of course. Of course we will. Not just undies, but a whole torso, the whole shebang. There is nothing Rain Wilson loves more than exposing his torso. It's exposing Dwight's belly. It's true. I had to know. I took a screen grab. I texted it to Rain, and I said, Rain, are these your green undies? Were they actually yours? And this is what he wrote back. And I quote, those were provided by wardrobe, my love. So I said, oh my God, Rain, you had to have a wardrobe meeting about underwear. And these were the pair that were picked. It's interesting because if you look, there are a few other times on the show where Dwight is in his underwear, like when he's sleeping on the couch. Yes.
Dwight穿着一条绿色内裤。当然了。我们当然会看到。不仅仅是内裤，而是整个躯干，整套装备。Rain Wilson没有比露出躯干更喜欢的事了。就是露出Dwight的肚子。确实如此。我必须弄个明白。我截了屏。我把它发短信给Rain，我说：“Rain，这是你的绿色内裤吗？真的是你自己的吗？”他是这么回我的。原话是：“那是服装组提供的，亲爱的。”所以我说：“哦，天呐，Rain，你还得为内裤开个服装会议。最后选中的就是这条。”有趣的是，如果你注意的话，剧集中还有其他几次Dwight穿着内裤出场的镜头，比如他在沙发上睡觉的时候。没错。
We had a fan question from Joanna K, Margaret F, and Natalia L. During the scene where Dwight is buckling his pants, after showing Michael that he isn't wearing a wire, do I hear a rooster crowing in the background? Yes, guys. Yes, you do. It's at 13 minutes, 34 seconds. There was a house in our vicinity, and they had some chickens on a rooster, and it was a challenge. Yeah. Because you can't make a rooster not crow when it wants to crow. Also, Jenna, do you remember the year that there was like a flock of parrots that were living in that tree? And they, parrots are so loud, you guys. They're like,
我们收到了来自Joanna K.、Margaret F.和Natalia L.的粉丝提问。在Dwight向Michael证明自己没有带窃听器、正在扣裤子扣子的那个场景里，我是不是听到背景里有公鸡在打鸣？是的，伙计们。是的，你们没听错。就在13分34秒。我们附近有一所房子，他们养了一些鸡和一只公鸡，这可给我们出了个难题。没错。因为你没法让一只公鸡在它想打鸣的时候不打鸣。还有，Jenna，你还记得有一年，有一群鹦鹉住在那个树上吗？它们，鹦鹉的声音真的超级大，伙计们。它们就像是，
so I was like. And when they're in a group, they get a bolster of confidence. They really do. They're super chatty. I remember this because I was like, Kenneth Paul, who did my makeup. I was like, there is a flock of parrots. And he said, Angela Faith, because he always called you by your first and middle name, he said, Angela Faith, don't you mean a pandemonium of parrots? Is that what a group of parrots is called? I guess so. Oh. We also had a fan question from Charlotte M. She's wondering, where the heck is Rain Wilson's mic pack, right? Yeah.
我就想。当它们聚在一起时，它们的自信心就会爆棚。真的会的。它们太吵了。我记得这事，因为我当时对负责我妆容的Kenneth Paul说。我说：“有一群鹦鹉。”他说：“Angela Faith”（因为他总是连名带姓地叫你），他说：“Angela Faith，难道你不知道一群鹦鹉应该叫作‘群魔乱舞’吗？”一群鹦鹉是这么叫的吗？我猜是的。哦。我们还收到了来自Charlotte M.的粉丝提问。她想知道，Rain Wilson的麦克风发射器到底藏在哪儿了？对啊。
I'll tell you what, there was no mic pack. They had to capture all of his sound on a boom microphone only. Yeah. They couldn't fit it under his paws. So. What has happened to you? That's champagne. That's the champagne talking.
我告诉你吧，根本没有什么发射器。他们只能完全靠挑杆麦克风来收录他的声音。是的。他们没法把它塞进他的裤子缝里。所以。你怎么了？那是香槟。那是香槟在作祟。
That crept up on us. It did. Slowly. Champagne sneaks up on you. That's the problem with champagne. Champagne makes me fun. It does? Yeah.
不知不觉就上头了。确实。慢慢地。香槟后劲挺大。这就是香槟的问题所在。香槟让我变得很有趣。是吗？对啊。
What can I expect from this afternoon? I had to stop drinking it because I have to drive home. Lady, we skipped something a while back and I want to bring it up. It's when Andy's in the kitchen and Jim enters. and he's doing like this whole melodrama of messing up a sales call. He's beating himself up and he... It's like he's in a soap opera. Yes.
我今天下午能期待什么？我不得不戒酒，因为我得开车回家。女士，我们刚才跳过了一些内容，我想提一下。那就是安迪在厨房里，吉姆进来了，他像在演一出夸张的肥皂剧，表现得自己把一次销售电话搞砸了一样。他自责不已，而且他……就像在演肥皂剧一样。是的。
And then he like drop kicks his lunch across the room. And steps on it? Yes. We got some fan mail. People wanted to know if that lunch bit was an improv. It was not. In fact, in the script it said, Jim drop kicks his lunch bag. So I just want to say what that means.
然后他一脚把午餐踢飞过整个房间。还踩在上面？是的。我们收到了一些粉丝来信。人们想知道那个午餐的桥段是不是即兴发挥。并不是。事实上，剧本里写的是：吉姆一脚踢飞了他的午餐袋。所以我只想说明这意味着什么。
When there's that simple line in a script that says, Jim drop kicks is lunch bag. lunch bag. When Phil Shea is going through a script and he sees that sentence, he's going to highlight that. Right. He's going to go to production and he's going to say, how many takes of this scene do you think we'll do? How many lunch bags do I need to make? How many sandwiches do I need to make? All of it. He'll probably also go to John and say, what are the odds you improvised taking a bite of it after you kick it? What kind of sandwich do you want in there? Everything. He would be so meticulous and then he would have to make a bunch of identical lunch bags.
当剧本里有这么一句简单的话写着“吉姆一脚踢飞了他的午餐袋”。午餐袋。当菲尔·谢（Phil Shea）浏览剧本并看到这句话时，他会把它高亮标出来。没错。他会去找制作组，然后说：“你们觉得这场戏我们要拍几条？我需要准备多少个午餐袋？我需要准备多少个三明治？全部都要。”他可能还会去找约翰，说：“你踢完之后顺便咬一口的几率有多大？你想要里面装什么三明治？所有的东西。”他会极其一丝不苟，然后他必须制作一堆一模一样的午餐袋。
And then like before, we would have a crew member off camera ready to fly in. That's the lingo. Fly in a new lunch bag. And they would also probably have John try to kick it into the same corner every time. Yes, that is how that little bitty sentence affected a bunch of people. Now, lady, it's time to go to Alfredo's. Yeah. Michael Pam and Ryan are going to go to Alfredos.
就像之前一样，我们会安排一个工作人员在镜头外准备“空投”。这是行话。空投一个新的午餐袋。而且他们可能还会让约翰每次都试着把它踢进同一个角落。是的，这正是那小小的一句话对许多人产生的影响。好了，女士，是时候去阿尔弗雷多餐厅了。对。迈克尔、帕姆和瑞恩要去阿尔弗雷多餐厅。
supposed to be meeting Dwight there because they're supposed to be, like, reconciling at Alfredo's Pizza Cafe. Dwight is such a good liar because I feel like the lying is in the details. Mm-hmm. And he knew he was never going to meet Michael for lunch. No, he's actually putting a fish in their ceiling. Yes, he's sabotaging them. He loves to sabotage. He's stealing Michael's Rolodex. Right. He knew he wasn't going to go. And Michael said, how about Cooper's? And Dwight's like, No, I had fish last week. Alfredo's. Like, this is really sneaky.
本该在那里跟德怀特碰面，因为他们原本打算去“阿尔弗雷多比萨咖啡馆”化解矛盾。德怀特真是个出色的骗子，因为我觉得谎言往往藏在细节里。嗯哼。而且他知道自己根本不会去和迈克尔吃午饭。不，他其实是在他们天花板里藏了一条鱼。是的，他在搞破坏。他太喜欢搞破坏了。他偷了迈克尔的名片盒。没错。他知道自己不会去。迈克尔说：“库珀餐厅怎么样？”德怀特却说：“不，我上周吃过鱼。去阿尔弗雷多餐厅吧。”就像这样，这真的很阴险。
Very much so. Yeah. Well, Randy told us that the vent where Dwight throws the fish was not real, and it was actually kind of difficult to construct, that Michael Gallenberg had to consult with our builder, Tim James, and they had to, like, drop the ceiling and create this vent. and they also had to build in sort of like a plastic receptacle to catch that fish because the fish was real. What?
非常是这样。嗯。嗯，兰迪告诉我们，德怀特扔鱼进去那个通风口并不是真的，而且建造起来其实有点困难，迈克尔·盖伦伯格（Michael Gallenberg）不得不咨询我们的布景搭建师蒂姆·詹姆斯（Tim James），他们不得不把天花板吊顶降低并造出这个通风口。他们还得内置某种塑料容器来接住那条鱼，因为那条鱼是真的。什么？
It was a real fish. You're kidding me. No. It was a real dead fish. I mean, it was like a fish they bought at the store. Right. So it was a dead fish. It was a dead fish.
那是条真鱼。你在开玩笑吧。没有。那是一条真正的死鱼。我的意思是，那就像是他们从店里买的鱼。没错。所以那是条死鱼。那是条死鱼。
Stinky dead fish. Wait a second. Let me understand this correctly. They had to build a fake ceiling. Yeah. With a fake drop down. With a fake vent. That could also hold dead fish.
臭烘烘的死鱼。等一下。让我好好理解一下。他们不得不搭建一个假天花板。对。带有一个可以降落的假结构。带有一个假通风口。还能装死鱼。
Yeah, it would have fallen through otherwise. Yeah, I can't believe we didn't use a faky fish. I was shocked. Yeah. Randy said it was a real fish. I wasn't there. You know, later when we come in and discover it, we're totally faking that we smell it. It was gone by then.
对，不然鱼就会掉下来了。对啊，我真不敢相信我们居然没用一条假鱼。我当时惊呆了。对。兰迪说那是条真鱼。我当时不在场。你知道的，后来当我们走进房间发现它时，我们完全是装出闻到恶臭的样子。那时候鱼其实已经不在了。
So wait a second. At the end in that montage, you guys take the fish out of the ceiling. Did you have to touch a real dead fish? Oh, my gosh, lady. I, first of all, I did not remember that we did that. seen, even though I watched this episode three times, I was clearly so distracted by Dwight's sleeves that you didn't notice you touched a fish. And I have no memory of it. But I mean, I guess we did. According to Randy, I guess I did touch a dead fish. Have you ever done a prank
所以等一下。最后在那个蒙太奇片段里，你们把鱼从天花板里拿出来了。你们得去摸一条真正的死鱼吗？哦，天哪，女士。首先，我不记得我们做过那个场景了，尽管我看了这集三遍，我显然被德怀特的袖子分散了注意力，以至于你都没注意到自己摸了一条鱼。我对此毫无记忆。不过，我想我们确实摸了。根据兰迪的说法，我确实摸了一条死鱼。你有没有搞过什么恶作剧？
like that? No. No? I don't like pranks. Okay. You know me. I know you. I in college, I had a group of friends who got really into pranking. They were like next level pranksters. Here's an example. They took a dead fish and they put it in the back of this guy, Nick's toilet. They lifted the back of the toilet and they put that fish in the toilet water, you know, that's in the back. No one ever lifts that thing. Unless your toilet's not flushing and you've got to jiggle that little thing, no one lifts the back of the toilet. No.
像这样的？没有。没有？我不喜欢恶作剧。好吧。你了解我。我了解你。我在大学里有一群朋友，他们非常热衷于恶作剧。他们简直是高手中的高手。举个例子。他们拿了一条死鱼，把它塞进这个叫尼克（Nick）的家伙的马桶水箱后面。他们掀开马桶水箱盖，把那条鱼塞进了水箱的水里，你知道的，就是后面的水箱。根本没有人会掀开那个东西。除非你的马桶冲不下水了，你得去拨弄一下那个小机关，否则根本没人会掀开马桶水箱盖。不。
No. Yeah. That fish was there a long time. Did it get so stinky? It got so stinky. We would go over to Nick. He lived in a house. with a group of guys. And we'd be like, God, Nick, your house stinks. He's like, I know, it's
没有。对。那条鱼在那里待了很久。是不是臭气熏天？臭得要命。我们会去尼克家。他住在一栋房子里。和一群男生合租。我们会说：“天哪，尼克，你们家太臭了。”他说：“我知道，是 plumbing（管道）还是什么的。
the plumbing or something. I've had three different guys out here. Couldn't figure out what it was for like a month. Oh, this is so disgusting. It's so disgusting. And then there's a certain point where the smell really zeroes in on one area. And he finally lift the back thing. And it was so foul. It was like maggots and disgustingness. He wasn't noticing. that like the water in his toilet was affected? I don't know what to tell you, lady. I don't know what to tell you. Did Nick find this amusing?
我找了三个不同的师傅来过了。折腾了一个月都没找出原因。”哦，这太恶心了。太恶心了。然后到了某个时候，那股臭味真的集中在了一个区域。他终于掀开了水箱盖。里面简直惨不忍睹。全是蛆虫和恶心的东西。他难道没有注意到他马桶里的水受影响了吗？我不知道该对你说什么，女士。我不知道该对你说什么。尼克觉得这很有趣吗？
Oh, it was on. After that, it really, the pranking got really out of control. They got really into pranking. Here's my thing about pranking. What? For me personally, to like get through a day. Yeah. Just with my own thoughts in my head and everything life is throwing at me.
哦，好戏开场了。从那以后，恶作剧真的彻底失控了。他们对恶作剧深陷其中。我对恶作剧的看法是这样的。什么？对我个人而言，为了度过一天。是的。光是应付我脑子里的想法以及生活抛给我的一切。
Yes. You know what I don't need? A prank. Your prank. Yeah. I don't need it. Yeah. Although I did do one Christmas prank once to someone.
是的。你知道我不需要什么吗？恶作剧。你的恶作剧。是的。我不需要它。是的。虽然我确实搞过一次圣诞恶作剧。
What? What? It was like, you know, a group thing and you were specifically supposed to do a joke gift. Right. And I had to come up with like a joke Christmas present. So what I did was the roommate of the person's name who I picked. Yeah. I said over the course of one month, will you slowly just sort of steal things from your roommate, like a
什么？什么？就像是，你知道的，一个团体活动，要求你专门准备一份恶作剧礼物。没错。我得想出一份像样的圣诞恶作剧礼物。所以我做的是，我找到了我抽到的那个人的室友。是的。我说，在一个月的时间里，你能不能慢慢地从你的室友那里偷走一些东西，比如
single shoe. Like, I gave them a list of things. Oh, you're the slow play. Yeah. I was just like, have little things go missing. Like maybe favorite coffee mug. And then at the very end, toothbrush. And then at the Christmas party, I had wrapped up all of the missing items into a box. And then that was the gift. Oh, that's kind of fun. All your stuff that's gone missing for a month. Yeah. That was my joke gift. I like that. I am not much of a prankster. I'm a lame pranker. Well, I'm glad you're a lame pranker lady because I don't want pranks in my life and you're my BFF. And so I'm happy they don't have a BFF that is like devoted to pranking. Yeah, that would really suck, wouldn't it?
单只鞋。比如，我给了他们一张清单。哦，你玩的是持久战。是的。我只是说，让一些小物件慢慢消失。比如也许是他最喜欢的咖啡杯。然后在最后，是牙刷。接着在圣诞派对上，我把所有失踪的物品都打包进了一个盒子里。然后那就是礼物。哦，那挺有意思的。你所有失踪了一个月的物品。是的。那就是我的恶作剧礼物。我喜欢这个。我不怎么搞恶作剧。我是个蹩脚的恶作剧者。好吧，我很高兴你是个蹩脚的恶作剧者，女士，因为我不希望我的生活里有恶作剧，而你是我的闺蜜。所以我很高兴我的闺蜜不热衷于恶作剧。是的，那真的很糟糕，对吧？
It really would. I have a location breakdown for Alfredo's Pizza Cafe. Let's hear it. This was a restaurant in Woodland Hills, California, called Nicholas. And it is owned by a husband and wife that were friends with our set designer Michael Gallenberg. Oh. And Randy said that we did not have to. to do much redressing of this restaurant at all. We were able to pretty much just use it as it was.
确实如此。我有关于“阿尔弗雷多比萨咖啡馆”的取景地详细资料。说来听听。这是加州伍德兰希尔斯的一家餐厅，名叫尼古拉（Nicholas）。它由一对夫妇拥有，他们和我们的布景设计师迈克尔·盖伦伯格（Michael Gallenberg）是朋友。哦。兰迪说我们根本不需要对这家餐厅做太多的重新布置。我们基本上可以直接原封不动地使用它。
That's great. Randy would also like you to know that Nicholas has the best chopped salad in the valley. I looked it up. It looks really good and it costs $16. I would love a chop salad right now. I know. That's what we should do after. Let's swing by Nicholas or something. And have a chop salad? Have a chopped salad. Well, in order to shoot this scene, we had to get there at 6.30 in the morning. And we had to shoot at 7.30 because we had to do it before the restaurant was open. But after this, BJ and I just got to go home. That's all I had to do that day. I remember I was back home by like 10 a.m.
那太棒了。兰迪还想让你知道，尼古拉餐厅拥有山谷里最好的切碎沙拉。我查了一下。看起来真的很棒，而且售价 16 美元。我现在就想吃一份切碎沙拉。我知道。我们待会儿应该去那儿。顺便去一趟尼古拉餐厅什么的。去吃一份切碎沙拉？去吃一份切碎沙拉。好吧，为了拍这场戏，我们必须在早上 6 点半到达那里。而且我们必须在 7 点半开始拍，因为我们必须在餐厅开门营业前拍完。不过拍完之后，我和 BJ 就可以直接回家了。那天我需要做的事就这些。我记得我大概早上 10 点就到家了。
My workday was done. Steve and the rest of the crew did a whole day of locations. But while I was looking at the call sheet, I saw this fascinating detail, which was the van schedule. Ooh. Do you remember these van schedules when we would shoot on location lady? No. You don't? Oh, see, this is the thing I used to love to do where I read every detail of a call sheet.
我的工作日就结束了。史蒂夫和剧组的其他人则拍了一整天的外景。不过当我看着通告单时，我看到了一个引人入胜的细节，那就是面包车（保姆车）时刻表。哦。女士，当我们在外景拍摄时，你还记得这些面包车时刻表吗？不记得。你不记得？哦，看吧，这就是我以前喜欢做的事，我会阅读通告单上的每一个细节。
Yes, you would. I would show up and be like, why is Access Hollywood here? And you'd be like, Angela, it's on the call sheet. And they put a memo in your trailer probably last week. I stepped right over that piece of paper. She really would. There would be a pile of memos on her floor. I kicked the papers to the side.
是的，你会的。我会现身然后说：“《走近好莱坞》（Access Hollywood）为什么会在这里？”而你会说：“安吉拉，通告单上写着呢。而且他们可能上周就已经把备忘录放进你的保姆车里了。”我直接从那张纸上踩了过去。她真的会这样。她的地板上会堆满备忘录。我把文件一脚踢到一边。
All right. So when you shoot on location, you park your car and they have the hair and makeup trailers in a big parking lot and they call it base camp. This is where the caterers will set up their. food tent. It's where you eat lunch. But a lot of times, base camp is really far away from the actual shooting location, and that was the case here. It was about a 15-minute van ride to get from base camp to Nicola's restaurant. So they had to have a van schedule to shuttle all of these people to set. And here's what it said. It said breakfast would be available as of 515, and then you could take one of six vans to set. They left at first.
好了。所以当你们在外景拍摄时，你把车停好，他们会在一个大停车场里搭好化妆间，这叫大本营。餐饮服务商会在那里搭起他们的食物帐篷。那是你吃午饭的地方。但很多时候，大本营距离实际拍摄地点非常远，这次就是这样。从大本营坐面包车到尼古拉餐厅大约需要 15 分钟。所以他们必须有一份面包车时刻表，把所有人接送到片场。情况是这样的：早餐从 5 点 15 分开始供应，然后你可以乘坐六辆面包车之一前往片场。它们出发的第一班是：
5.42 a.m. 6 a.m. 6. 12 a.m. And they designated this van for our grip and electric crew. 6.30 a.m. And then there was one last van at 642 a.m. And in all caps, it said, this is the late van. You did not want to be on the late van. Don't do it. No, no, no, no. There were also additional shuttles for the cast and the background actors that were set to leave at 7 a.m. So the idea was, the crew would get there, set up all the lights, and then the actors would land. The hair and makeup folks would ride with the actors. That's the van schedule. That was Randy's job to make that van schedule. He did a fantastic job. So Dwight never makes it to the restaurant. He calls and says he hit a bear. And Michael just believes it. Not just Michael. I will have you know that Pam and Ryan
早上 5 点 42 分。6 点。早上 6 点 12 分。他们把这辆面包车指定为我们的灯光和电力剧组专用。早上 6 点 30 分。然后还有最后一辆车，在早上 6 点 42 分。上面全是大写字母写着：这是末班车。你绝对不想坐上末班车。千万别坐。不，不，不，不。此外，还有为演员和群演准备的额外班车，定于早上 7 点出发。所以安排是这样的：剧组人员先到达，架好所有的灯光，然后演员们再到场。发型和化妆人员将与演员们同车抵达。这就是面包车时刻表。制作这份面包车时刻表是兰迪的工作。他做得棒极了。所以德怀特根本没去成餐厅。他打电话说他撞了一头熊。而迈克尔居然就信了。不只是迈克尔。我得提醒你，帕姆和瑞恩
don't even raise an eyebrow. They don't even look up from their menu when Michael says Dwight hit a bear, but he's on the way. How many bears? How many bears? Where's has Dwight hit? Why is this so believable? They get back to Michael Scott Paper Company. They discover they've been robbed. Dwight calls. Michael is like, I don't have time to talk. We've been robbed. And once again, Pam and mine are like, it was Dwight. Yeah. This is when Dwight is going to start poaching the clients off the Rolodex. And to get back at him, Michael is going to eat his meatball parm that he brought back for him, which is so funny. Because Dwight says, I knew you were going to do that. And that's why I made you order it because it's the worst thing on their menu. And then the way Steve is so disgusted by it. Why is it so funny to watch Steve eat food that he's disgusted with? Anything with food. It's hilarious.
甚至连眉头都没皱一下。当迈克尔说德怀特撞了一头熊但正在赶来时，他们连菜单都没抬头看一眼。几头熊？几头熊？德怀特撞了什么地方？为什么这这么容易让人相信？他们回到迈克尔·斯科特纸业公司。他们发现自己被抢劫了。德怀特打来电话。迈克尔说：“我没时间说话。我们被抢劫了。”而帕姆和瑞恩再一次觉得：“那就是德怀特干的。”是的。这时候德怀特开始从名片盒里挖走客户。为了报复他，迈克尔决定吃掉德怀特给他带回来的肉丸帕尔马干酪三明治，这太搞笑了。因为德怀特说：“我早就知道你会这么干。这就是为什么我让你点这个，因为这是他们菜单上最难吃的东西。”然后史蒂夫表现得那么反感，那样子太绝了。为什么看史蒂夫吃他自己感到恶心的食物会这么好笑？任何跟食物有关的。都太爆笑了。
Well, in Casual Friday, he's going to eat everybody's lunch and it's very, very funny. I can't wait to get to that. There's some good bloopers from that, too. Listen, there was a deleted scene. As Dwight is poaching everyone's clients, he really crosses the line with Ryan. because Ryan's uncle chooses Dwight over the Michael Scott Paper Company. What? Yeah, and there's some really good Pam Sass. We got to hear it.
嗯，在《休闲星期五》那一集里，他会吃掉每个人的午餐，非常非常搞笑。我迫不及待想要看到那一集了。里面还有一些很棒的失误镜头呢。听着，还有一个被删减的片段。随着德怀特抢走所有人的客户，他在瑞恩身上真的有点过界了。因为瑞恩的叔叔选择了德怀特，而不是迈克尔·斯科特纸业公司。什么？对，里面还有一些帕姆的经典毒舌。我们得听听。
Dwight just got Howard Family dry cleaners. Uncle Dave? A little jerk is undercutting us big time. He is actually taking a loss and paying the difference out of pocket. That's my family. When you mess with my family, I can't be responsible for my actions. When are you ever responsible for your actions? Get off my ass, you hag.
德怀特刚拿下了霍华德家族干洗店。戴夫叔叔？那个小混蛋在狠狠地压我们的价。他其实是在亏本做生意，自己掏腰包补足差价。那可是我的家人。当你跟我的家人过不去时，我对自己的行为可就负不了责了。你什么时候对自己的行为负过责？少烦我，你这个老太婆。
Hey, hey, hey, hey, something about that seems inappropriate. Something about that seems inappropriate. You can't put his finger on it. I love the Brian Pam, like, rivalry. I just live for it. I love it, too. I mean, I just loved working with these guys for this period of time. I bet it was so much fun.
嘿，嘿，嘿，嘿，这句话听起来好像不太合适。这句话听起来好像不太合适。你就是说不出哪里不对。我太喜欢布莱恩和帕姆这种针锋相对的关系了。我简直为之疯狂。我也很喜欢。我的意思是，我只是太喜欢在这个时期和这些家伙一起工作了。我敢打赌这一定超级有趣。
Well, now we're going to get into a pretty fun bit where Michael is going to walk in to Harper Collins. with Dwight on the phone. He's like, I'm going to let you listen to me still, your biggest client. And Dwight's like, no, and takes off. And he gets in the car all the while listening. That was so funny. Rain in the car when he was like, paper is the manure. And on time delivery is the soil. I wrote down that quote too. Do I need that on a mug? We might need it on a mug. Paper is the manure. We had a fan question from Sydney S who said, How did you guys film that scene of Dwight driving to Mr. Schofield's office?
好了，现在我们要进入一个非常有趣的桥段，迈克尔要走进哈珀·柯林斯出版社（Harper Collins）。手里还打着德怀特的电话。他说：“我要让你听着我拿下你最大的客户。”而德怀特说：“不”，然后飞奔出去。他一边听着电话一边上了车。那一幕太搞笑了。雷恩在车里说：“纸张是粪肥。按时交付是土壤。”我也把这句台词记下来了。我需要把它印在马克杯上吗？我们可能真的需要把它印在马克杯上。纸张是粪肥。我们有一个来自悉尼 S 的粉丝提问，她说：你们是怎么拍摄德怀特开车去肖菲尔德先生办公室那个场景的？
Was Steve really on the other end of the phone? No, Steve was not on the other end of the phone. And I talked with Randy about this. Rain is really driving. He's free driving. He is not hooked up to anything. It looked like it to me, just the way he pulled into the parking lot. Yeah, the whole time.
史蒂夫真的在电话那头吗？不，史蒂夫不在电话那头。我和兰迪聊过这件事。雷恩是真的在开车。他是自由驾驶。他没有被连接到任何拖车设备上。我看他开进停车场的样子确实像。是的，全程都是。
So they had LAPD officers on motor. motorcycles. So no one would sort of interfere with the shot or rain driving. Yes, correct. And there's also a crew van following behind. But here's how they got that shot. Matt Sown, our camera operator, was in the front seat. Oh. Filming rain. Our sound engineer, Ben Patrick, was in the backseat recording sound, and our director, Paul Fieg, was also in the backseat. That was not a big backseat. I have been in that car. That is tiny. I know. And Randy said, we did not have a two-way phone setup. It was just too unreliable. And so Randy's guess is that Paul Figue was reading Steve's dialogue so that Rain could react to it. Yeah. Amazing.
所以他们有洛杉矶警察局的摩托车警员开道。这样就不会有人干扰拍摄或雷恩开车。是的，没错。后面还跟着一辆剧组的面包车。但他们是这样拍到那个镜头的：我们的摄影师马特·索恩（Matt Sown）坐在前排座位上。哦。拍摄雷恩。我们的录音师本·帕特里克（Ben Patrick）坐在后排录音，我们的导演保罗·费格（Paul Feig）也坐在后排。那可不是个大后盘座位。我坐过那辆车。空间非常小。我知道。兰迪说，我们当时没有设置双向通话系统。那样太不稳定了。所以兰迪猜测，保罗·费格当时在念史蒂夫的台词，好让雷恩做出反应。是的。太神奇了。
I wish we had a picture of those four guys in the car. Can we talk about what happens when Dwight arrives at Mr. Schofield's office? Finally? I lived for this. I had to know if this was scripted or improvised. So Dwight is going to run in. First of all, he's changing into his mustard shirt. I loved that detail. I loved that detail. And then when he gets to the receptionist, he does this crazy spin move. And then Dwight says spin move. And I was like, did Rain improvise that?
我真希望能有一张那四个家伙挤在车里的照片。我们能聊聊当德怀特终于到达肖菲尔德先生办公室时发生了什么吗？我太爱这个桥段了。我必须知道这是剧本写的还是即兴发挥的。所以德怀特跑了进去。首先，他换上了他的芥末黄衬衫。我太喜欢这个细节了。我太喜欢这个细节了。然后当他走到前台时，他做了一个疯狂的旋转动作。接着德怀特说了一句“旋转动作”。当时我就想：那是雷恩即兴发挥的吗？
I've got to know. Jenna, it was 100% in the script. Everything. Even the spin move, all of it. I found an old interview with Rain where he said that one time he did a somersault. And he said he thought that it would look extra stealthy. When they watched it back, it looked. quote, like a manatee doing ballet at SeaWorld.
我必须知道。詹娜，这 100% 是剧本里写的。全部都是。甚至连旋转动作，全都是。我找到了一篇雷恩的旧采访，他说有一次他做了一个前滚翻。他说他以为那样看起来会格外隐秘。但当他们回看录像时，看起来——引述原话——“就像一只海牛在海洋世界里跳芭蕾”。
He also said they did about five takes. I also have a little guest star breakdown for Mr. Schofield's receptionist. She was played by Angela Campola Sanders, who was our casting associate on the office since season four. This is her only acting credit. That's awesome. But she played Mr. Schofield's receptionist. Pretty much everyone in our casting office made it into the episode at some point. I love that. I do too. Dwight is about to dig himself into a big old hole because he doesn't understand Michael's Rolodex or Michael's color coding info. Michael has a talking head where he says, I color code all my info. I wrote gay sun and green. Green means go so I know to go ahead and shut up about it. Yes. And orange means orange is glad you didn't bring it up. Most colors mean don't say it. Yeah, but Dwight doesn't know that. Yeah. So Dwight is basically saying all the things that are color coded to not.
他还说他们大约拍了五条。我还准备了一个关于肖菲尔德先生前台接待员的客串演员小档案。她由安吉拉·坎波拉·桑德斯（Angela Campola Sanders）饰演，她从第四季开始就是我们在《办公室》的选角助理。这是她唯一的演艺经历。这太棒了。但她饰演了肖菲尔德先生的前台。几乎我们选角办公室里的每个人都在某个时刻客串进了这一集。我太喜欢这个了。我也是。德怀特正要把自己推进一个大坑里，因为他根本不懂迈克尔的名片盒或迈克尔的颜色编码信息。迈克尔有一个独白镜头，他说：我把我的所有信息都用颜色编码了。我把“同性恋”写在太阳上，用的是绿色。绿色代表通行，所以我知道该继续闭嘴别多说废话。是的。而橙色代表……橙色代表很高兴你没提这事。大部分颜色都代表别说。是的，但德怀特并不知道。所以德怀特基本上把所有那些被颜色编码为“绝对不能说”的事情全都说了出来。
be said. Right. Well, before we wrap up this heavy competition between Mike, wait, this Mike, this episode, that's the champagne. I know. And the champagne, you have a nickname for everyone and your champagne brain. Mike. Mike. Dwighty. Um, okay. I think we should go back and wrap up this Andy Jim storyline. Okay. We both had to stop drinking champagne, by the way. We did. It just, it's so interesting. Scotch and Splenda was like, waboo, waboo, but champagne, we're like, I can't talk right now. Yeah, I still really do love the scotch and splendor. Me too. I have to say, it's a really good drink. And we got some letters from people who said it's basically an old-fashioned. If we'd added a few orange bitters, and that's what it tasted like to me. That's right. Because I guess you would add like a sugar, a muddled kind of sugary syrup to the scotch. And so that's what the splen. Linda is doing.
没错。好吧，在我们结束这场迈克，等等，这个迈克，这一集，这就是香槟的功劳。我懂的。而且喝了香槟，你给每个人都起了外号，这就是你的“香槟大脑”。迈克。迈克。小德怀特。嗯，好吧，我觉得我们应该回去收尾安迪和吉姆的这条故事线。好。顺便说一句，我们俩都不得不停止喝香槟了。我们确实停了。这真是太有趣了。苏格兰威士忌加代糖喝起来就像“哇呜，哇呜”，但香槟一喝，我们就变成“我现在不会说话了”。对，我其实还是真的很喜欢苏格兰威士忌加代糖。我也是。我得说，这真是一款很不错的饮品。而且我们收到了一些人的来信，说这基本上就是一杯老式鸡尾酒（Old Fashioned）。如果我们加一点橙味苦精的话，那就是我喝出来的那个味道。没错。因为我猜你会在苏格兰威士忌里加入像糖浆一样捣碎的东西。所以这就是代糖在起到的作用。
Yeah. But champagne just makes us go, what? What are we talking about? What's happening? I know. All right. See? I know.
对。但香槟只会让我们变成：什么？我们在说什么？发生什么事了？我知道。好吧？看？我懂的。
I'm like, what am I talking about? Okay, so Andy and Jim, Andy is going to tell the whole bullpen that Jim is upset. And Phyllis is going to be like, Andy, I think Jim is just messing with you. And then there's that smug shot of Jim in the kitchen looking out through the blinds with that grin on his face. We had a fan question from Rhea H and Poonette B. Can we talk about how do she Jim is being in this episode? Andy was being really supportive and genuinely cared for Jim. And while Andy's concern might have been misguided or nosy,
我就像是在说，我在胡说些什么啊？好吧，所以安迪和吉姆，安迪要告诉整个办公室说吉姆很难过。而菲尔斯会说：“安迪，我觉得吉姆只是在捉弄你。”然后就是那个吉姆在厨房里通过百叶窗向外张望、脸上带着那种标志性坏笑的洋洋得意的镜头。我们收到了来自蕾亚·H（Rhea H）和普妮特·B（Poonette B）的粉丝提问。我们能聊聊吉姆这一集里的行为有多混蛋吗？安迪一直非常支持吉姆，并且是真心关心他。虽然安迪的关心可能是错付了或者是爱管闲事，
I think it came from a good place. We'd really like to get your take on this prank that Jim pulls on Andy because we think the prank might have been a little mean-spirited. I didn't care for it. I didn't either. I do think this is a mean, spirited joke. I mean, we already know I don't like pranks, and I don't love especially pranks that at someone's expense, that play with their emotions. Right. I think it was too big of a reaction to Andy's kind of nosy meddling. And he does have this nice speech, Jim at the end to
我觉得他是出于好意。我们真的很想听听你们对吉姆捉弄安迪这个恶作剧的看法，因为我们觉得这个恶作剧可能有点刻薄。我并不觉得这有什么好。我也不觉得。我觉得这确实是一个刻薄的玩笑。我的意思是，我们已经知道我不喜欢恶作剧了，而且我尤其不喜欢那种以牺牲他人为代价、玩弄别人感情的恶作剧。没错。我觉得对于安迪那种爱管闲事的干预来说，吉姆的反应未免太过了。而且吉姆最后确实对安迪说了一番很好听的话。
Andy. He's like, listen, I know Angela broke your heart, but you're going to find someone else. You really will. So I feel like that was the moment where the writers were like, you know, Jim's not a bad guy. Maybe he was trying to show Andy something, but I just didn't like the prank. Me either. Yeah. Well, I'm glad we discussed that. Yeah. We're with you. So this episode ends with more cheeseball fun. Michael, Ryan, and Pam, they're trying to see how many cheese puffs can they fit in their mouth? 32. That's the record. Yeah. And then the phone rings and Michael answers it and he's got a mouthful of cheese puffs and we're all laughing. And while this is happening, you can hear a Michael talking head where he's saying he wanted to start a company and not a war.
他说：“听着，我知道安吉拉伤了你的心，但你会找到别人的。真的会的。”所以我觉得那是编剧们在说：“你知道的，吉姆不是个坏人。也许他只是想向安迪展示点什么。”但我就是不喜欢这个恶作剧。我也是。好吧，我很高兴我们讨论了这一点。对。我们和你们站在一起。所以这一集以更多有趣的奶酪球桥段结束。迈克尔、瑞恩和帕姆，他们试图看自己的嘴能塞进多少个奶酪泡芙？32个。纪录保持者。对。然后电话响了，迈克尔接了电话，他的嘴里塞满了奶酪泡芙，我们都在大笑。正当这一切发生时，你能听到迈克尔的一段独白，他说他想开创一家公司，而不是发动一场战争。
Well, this Talking Head was added later. This was not in the original script. Steve shot this a couple weeks after we shot the original episode. And all of this footage of us doing this cheese puffs bit, this was originally going to be at the end of the cold open. So was all of that was going to live at the top of the episode? Yes. But they thought it would be funnier to end the cold open on Pam getting the cheese puff.
好吧，这段独白是后来补拍加进去的。这原本并不在剧本里。史蒂夫是在我们拍完原版剧集几周后拍的这段。而且所有这些我们做奶酪泡芙桥段的素材，原本是打算放在冷开场（cold open）结尾的。所以所有这些原本都要放在这一集的开头吗？是的。但他们觉得以帕姆打着哈欠吃下奶酪泡芙来结束冷开场会更有趣。
while she's yawning. Mm-hmm. And then they gave this episode this new tag with the cheese ball bit. This was not the original tag for the episode. So instead of this bookend of cheese puffs at the beginning and end, there was a tag. And we did film it. And I want to share it with you guys. So Andy is in the conference room and he is selling off his wedding stuff.
嗯哼。然后他们给这一集加上了这个带有奶酪球桥段的新标签。这并不是这一集原本的标签。所以，没有采用开头和结尾这种奶酪泡芙的呼应，原本是有一个标签镜头的。而且我们确实拍了。我想跟你们分享一下。所以安迪在会议室里，正在拍卖他的婚礼用品。
He's determined. Still. Still. Well, you know, he didn't get buyers from Jim and Pam. So in the tag, he's selling it to the rest of the game. and they're all bidding on things. Stanley buys the rice bags, and Creed decides to get in on the action, too.
他很坚定。依然很坚定。好吧，你知道的，他在吉姆和帕姆那里没找到买家。所以在标签镜头里，他在把东西卖给其他同事，大家都在竞标。斯坦利买下了大米袋，而克里德也决定掺和进来分一杯羹。
I thought we had to hear a little bit of it. Why are you here, Stanley? I'll give for the rice. Boom, sold. 100 bags of rice, Stanley Hudson. Creed, how would you like a crispy new tuxedo for your funeral? I'll take the bottom half. I want to go out the same way I came in, shirtless.
我觉得我们得听一听其中的一小段。斯坦利，你为什么在这儿？我出价买大米。轰，成交。100袋大米，归斯坦利·哈德森所有。克里德，你的葬礼需要一套崭新酥脆的燕尾服吗？我要下半身。我想以我出生时的老样子离开——光着膀子。
And everyone else starts making bids, too, that asking questions on things. Angela is not in the scene, but she walks by and had this talking head. It was in the shooting draft. I don't know why I'm down. I guess I always thought that Andy would save the stuff from our wedding just in case. Now, it's stupid. Just in case I married someone else and he decided to throw us a wedding. I told you it was stupid. I guess there were some things in there that Angela liked. Yeah, and maybe she hoped would make a comfort. back. Oh, so there you have it, guys.
然后其他人也开始竞标，并对一些物品提出疑问。安吉拉没有出现在这个场景中，但她走过并有一段独白。这在拍摄剧本里是有的。我不知道我为什么会情绪低落。我想我总是以为安迪会把我们婚礼的东西留着，以防万一。现在看来，太蠢了。以防万一我嫁给别人，而他决定给我们办个婚礼。我早就告诉过你这很蠢。我猜里面确实有些安吉拉喜欢的东西。是的，也许她希望它能派上用场。回来。哦，所以就是这样，伙计们。
100 episodes. Oh, my gosh. Listen, Ange, we got this letter because, you know, I said I was going through the mail. Yeah. From Susanna G. And I wanted to share it. I really appreciated it. Okay, let's hear it.
100集。哦，天哪。听着，安吉，我们收到了这封信，因为，你知道的，我说过我在整理邮件。是的。来自苏珊娜·G（Susanna G）。我想把它分享出来。我真的很感激。好吧，说来听听。
Susanna says, not sure you'll see this, but I wanted to say something to you both. First, you are my people. You are silly, loud, honest, organized, Jenna, me too. And just so relatable. She didn't put Angela in there for organized. It's okay, Susanna. But more importantly, I noticed your value of mental health mainly depicted to me by the breaks that you take sometimes between podcast episodes. Not all podcasts do that.
苏珊娜说：“不确定你们能不能看到这个，但我想对你们两个说点什么。首先，你们是我的同类。你们傻气、大声、诚实、有条理——詹娜，我也是。而且超级接地气。”她没把安吉拉归进“有条理”那一类里。没关系，苏珊娜。但更重要的是，我注意到了你们对心理健康的重视，这主要体现在你们有时在播客单集之间进行的休息。并不是所有的播客都会这么做。
And as a fan, I always look forward to listening to next week's episode. So when I hear rerun content at times, it's initially a bummer. However, it's always followed by thoughts of, well, perhaps they needed more prep time so that they didn't have to sacrifice family time or self-care. And as a hustling mom with a career of my own, two small children and a law enforcement hubby with crazy schedules, demands, and stresses, my life is chaotic to say the least. But I'm learning more and more. My stability and that of my family comes from not sacrificing those two things. So I commend you for staying committed to your values and still,
作为粉丝，我总是期待着收听下一周的节目。所以每当我听到重播内容时，最初确实会觉得有点扫兴。然而，随之而来的总是这样的想法：‘嗯，也许他们需要更多准备时间，这样他们就不必牺牲陪伴家人的时间或自我关爱。’作为一位拥有自己事业的拼搏妈妈，要照顾两个幼小的孩子，还有一个日程疯狂、要求严格且压力巨大的执法部门老公，我的生活简直可以用混乱来形容。但我越来越深刻地认识到：我和家人的稳定性来自于不牺牲这两样东西。所以我赞扬你们坚守自己的价值观，同时还能
getting to do what you love and with your bestie. What a blessing. Maybe I got all this wrong and that's not what's going on at all, but if I'm on the nose, I simply want to offer encouragement to keep it up your way. I'll be waiting for next week's episode whenever you get to it, sending virtual hugs to you both. That is so sweet. Susanna, you got it 100% right. Yeah, I feel seen, Susanna. Yes, it really meant a lot to me because I feel like Angela and I are two gals with a very strong work ethic. We love making this show. But it is also important to us that we reserve holiday time, a little spring break time, a little summertime just for our families. Yeah. For our mental health breaks. And so we do take time off for that. You know, it also means that our team here gets a break. That's right. Everyone gets a break. So thank you, Susanna. I really appreciate it. And just know that we will put some fun stuff at the top of those rerun episodes so that we don't leave you hanging on those breaks.
做自己热爱的事，并且有闺蜜相伴。这真是天大的福气。也许我全猜错了，情况根本不是这样，但如果我猜对了，我只想鼓励你们继续按你们的方式坚持下去。无论你们什么时候更新，我都会等待下一周的节目，向你们俩发送虚拟的拥抱。”这太甜了。苏珊娜，你完全猜对了。是的，我觉得自己被看见了，苏珊娜。是的，这对我意义重大，因为我觉得我和安吉拉是两个有着极强职业道德的姑娘。我们热爱制作这个节目。但为我们的家人保留假期时间、一点春假时间、一点夏日时光对我们来说同样重要。是的。为了我们的心理健康假。所以我们确实会为此休假。你知道，这也意味着我们这里的团队也能休息。没错。每个人都能休息。所以谢谢你，苏珊娜。我真的很感激。并且请知道，我们会在那些重播节目的开头加入一些有趣的内容，这样我们在休假时就不会让你们悬着干等了。
That's right. And you guys, I really want to say thank you so much to Creed Bratton as well for doing that sweet little intro for us. And you guys, he has a new single that just dropped. It's called Breathe Easy. It's available on Apple Music. And I thought we could listen to a little bit of it as we say goodbye. Happy 100th episode. Happy 100.
没错。而且伙计们，我真的非常非常感谢克里德·布拉特（Creed Bratton）为我们做了那个可爱的小片头。还有伙计们，他刚刚发布了一首新单曲。它叫《放轻松》（Breathe Easy）。它在 Apple Music 上线了。我想我们在说再见时可以听一听其中的一小段。祝贺第 100 集快乐。第 100 集快乐。
Thank you for listening to Office Ladies' Second Drink. This episode was initially created in collaboration with Earwolf. Office Ladies is a presentation of Odyssey and is produced by Jenna Fisher and Angela Kinsey. Our senior producer is Matt Beagle. Our Second Drinks episodes are produced by Molly Nugent. Our audio engineer is Sam Pfeiffer. Odyssey's executive producer is Leah Reese Dennis. Office Ladies was mixed and mastered by Bill Shultz.
感谢收听《办公室女士的第二杯酒》。本集最初是与 Earwolf 合作创作的。《办公室女士》是 Odyssey 的一档节目，由詹娜·费舍尔和安吉拉·金西制作。我们的资深制作人是马特·比格尔（Matt Beagle）。我们的《第二杯酒》节目由莫莉·纽金特（Molly Nugent）制作。我们的音频工程师是萨姆·派弗（Sam Pfeiffer）。Odyssey 的执行制作人是莉亚·里斯·丹尼斯（Leah Reese Dennis）。《办公室女士》由比尔·舒尔茨（Bill Shultz）进行混音和母带制作。
Our theme song is Rubber Tree by Creed, Brad. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我们的主题曲是克里德·布拉特（Creed Bratton）的《橡胶树》（Rubber Tree）。本集还没有评论。点击剧本中的任意句子即可留下评论。